You don't want them to know,
boom and live Erik Griffin.
So we were talking before this podcast,
how you mix it up with the android
watch,
but the apple phone that's very curious
it.
We'll see.
I used to be all Samsung.
I love the android and the watches.
Great.
I love how it interacts,
but then I get a girlfriend who has an
iphone.
Right.
She's like,
I want to have face time with you,
so why don't you tell her to get skype,
skype APP.
You married,
you understand what you can't.
Anyway,
I got set standards.
Yeah.
Wow.
Hey,
I'm not the stamp lines in the sand,
but then they have like a.
They had this app on the apple now
called gear which lets you hook up your
phone but you can't really interact with
it.
You can't like talk or anything,
but it's actually kind of Nice.
You just want to know stuff's going on.
It's probably.
Yeah.
We were saying it's probably better that
you can't interact with it because Jamie
was telling me that they could do walkie
talkie with your iphones now.
Yeah.
They're still being announced right now.
So I don't know all the details,
but the worldwide developers conference
is going on the WWDC,
so they're not new operating system.
The new Apple Watch and the new all like
automatic workout detection,
walkie talkie mode and something else.
There's just too much.
I have an apple watch too.
I love it.
You can leave it at,
at least sometimes I'll leave my phone.
I don't even bring my phone with me,
you know,
because you can.
Uh.
Do you feel weird when you do that?
Because he's a rebel.
Here's what's happening now though,
like if I have my watch.
So when you look at your watch,
what does that cue he accused like you
want to go or you're missing out on or.
I know now when you do that it's just
because you're looking at a text
message.
So now it's just as rude as it just.
We're not.
This isn't helping.
It's not helping them.
When I go,
if I'm looking and you were talking and
I go like this,
I'm looked down and you think you just
have to go someplace.
Yeah.
No,
not just got a text too much,
right?
Yeah,
I just got a tweet,
I got to retweet.
I looking at,
you know,
that's what are we doing,
what are we doing?
I have no idea.
And you know,
what's really weird about all this
stuff?
The phones and how we talk.
Everybody wants to text like you can't
get people to call you.
You can't get people to a now and now
they're putting the little emojis.
Right?
Right.
And then from the mode,
now they're putting like gifts of real
people.
So this is how I feel.
So we're,
we're,
we're going in a circle because we want
human interaction,
we want connection,
we want to see people.
So now we're putting,
they're putting a celebrity up.
Like this is how I feel today.
Why don't you put how you feel today,
right?
Not Chris,
Pat Pratt,
rolling a garbage can or something.
This is my mood.
So we're slowly getting back to where
it's going to be.
We're going to actually be talking to a
real person thinks so you didn't come
all the way around or I think it's going
to come all the way around.
Hmm,
well this is this Jamie
thing.
They showed it's you're making a Emoji
of yourself called me Mochi.
They already do that with Sandra
Samsung,
like it's working in the wrapping them
off.
This is what I'm working together.
This is what I'm saying.
We're searching for trying to find ways
to be more ourselves.
You don't need an Emoji of yourself.
Just be yourself
that they're going against each other.
Oh,
there's tax on Samsung.
Ar Emoji.
Yeah.
They ripped off the idea for cheap
fucks.
Hakan on like ripping people off now.
They were first with the iphone.
The iphone was the first of these kinds
of things.
The first iphone,
but androids are real close now.
They're real close.
I mean it's very debate,
but everything after that they were
late,
like really?
Like on an android.
You could copy and paste on an android
three years before you could do it.
Oh right.
An apple.
So you've always been an android guy?
I've always been andrew guys get another
android.
I know I'm going girlfriend.
I'm the man.
You get an Android,
you get it.
You get an android,
little skype it.
It'll be me giving bite Hernandez,
native to Android,
like uh,
like the facetime thing is,
there's something that's on the revenue
they have,
like they have like their own version of
that.
They have their own version of that,
but I don't think people really use it.
They have their own like Samsung video
though.
But Samsung has one but just like what
if you have say like a Google Pixel
phone?
Yeah.
That they might have,
but I don't think enough people have a
google pixel phone to make that even a
thing.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I thought those were really popular.
And are they who?
Do you know if any one person you know,
that has a Google Pixel could call me.
I have one.
You know,
you do not have a Google Pixel.
Do have one?
Do you use it?
Okay.
So you were given a Google Bot one.
Why?
Because I wanted to try it out.
But here's what happened.
I couldn't get text messages to work.
This is the scam because you are hooked
up to this.
Uh,
what are you showing me?
Jamie said they do have it.
It's with the Pixel two or something
like that.
Maybe it's android video calling.
It just simplifies.
Enjoyed video calling.
Oh,
I'll get that.
So does that only work with android?
Android to android.
Okay.
I don't know why they don't just work
together.
Why does an apple example just work
together?
They don't work together with text
message.
See this.
My point is really annoying.
The I message thing is what?
Fuck me.
Because everybody knew that I had an
iphone so they would send me because
they have an iphone.
They would send me an I message and so I
was sending people text messages to like
I'm not getting it.
I'm like send me one and they would send
me one and I wouldn't get it.
And so then I went online and looked it
up and it said you have to disable I
message.
Okay.
So I disabled my message.
Then you have to call up.
You have to actually call up someone.
I'm done at that point.
At that point you have to call up
someone and tell them to take your email
address off of the I message database.
Okay.
So I do that and I say take this email.
Well why are you doing that sir?
Because I switched over to an android
phone.
There's like pause,
like I just fucking killed the queen.
Like come on,
like you heard an alarm go off.
I'm one of millions of fucking people
out there.
You don't know anything about me.
Why do you care?
Why would you give a fuck what they
like?
They literally,
the guy on the phone,
I felt bad that I was switching over.
So then,
um,
it still wouldn't.
I mean it didn't work for Dow.
Get like one out of three text messages
and it all happened while I was on
vacation.
I just figured I'm going to try this
phone while I'm on vacation.
Fuck around.
But you can't.
They got,
you roped in with that.
Goddamn that I messaged shit.
Yeah.
That's the apples thing.
No matter where you are in the world and
all that.
People have apple.
A lot of,
I think Samsung has taken over in terms
of life for android.
You know,
I love the Samsung phones,
didn't make good phones.
They make great phones.
The difference between the androids
though is that Samsung does not update
their software very often.
Their update,
they update security patches but they
don't need to.
But Google Pixel phones get the latest
software right when it gets released and
so like when Oreo comes out,
an eight point one,
all these different operating systems
come out there better supposedly for
like for how long a week.
I mean we know it takes a long time
before they come out on St.
on Samsung phones.
Long time.
Like six months sometimes.
Oh really?
Yeah.
It takes a long time.
Well there you go.
You heard it break the breaking news
right here.
Maybe that's what the problem was.
Yeah,
but it also.
Samsung puts their own shit over android
and Ios.
Real android dorks want pure android and
pure android.
You really only get with the pixel
unless you can.
Are you.
Do you know about how do you like,
can you hack them?
You can hack them,
right?
We can like how you use,
what do they call it?
Jail break your phone and all that kind
of stuff.
They've made that just common now
because it used to be like they,
they,
they would lock it down where like let's
say you had verizon,
so you could only use this phone on
verizon with verizon stuff and then you
would jailbreaker then you couldn't like
open it up to like all these other types
of apps.
If they would stop being greedy freaks,
just stop being so greedy.
Let me use my phone however I want.
I'm still going to be on your system.
I'm still paying your $200 a month for
your stupid phone.
A surface and you do a little,
a little extra,
extra little extra.
Don't get me started on that when you
started.
I know motherfucker and I can't believe
the shit we have to deal with.
Eric Griffin.
God dammit.
That was weird though,
man.
It's like,
it's weird.
There's only two.
That's also weird.
There's only two operating systems
heating side aside,
but that's how we are in our country.
We can only Republican or Democrat.
Apple or android.
Do you remember windows?
Phone.
Windows.
Phone wasn't bad.
It wasn't that bad.
I had a friend who had a windows phone.
I was like,
oh,
this is kinda cool.
It had tiles.
It was like windows 10 windows,
10 books with titles like a Cayman went.
Nobody cares about that and went look at
you just like I can't.
I can't deal with.
I don't want to hear what everybody's
trying to get into the phone game,
but what's crazy is how many people have
windows computers.
It's amazing that windows had a phone
and people are like,
Nah,
because they know all the problems they
had with their.
With their computer.
I stopped.
I can't even remember the last time I
had a windows.
I strictly went app because it's just so
easy to use and it's still not easy to
use.
You know what's not easy though?
I'm apple does not have good keyboards.
Like if you have a desktop keyboard at
home and you can add a second keyboard,
you know like by a mechanical keyboard.
If you're a writer,
if you like to write.
The problem with apple keyboards is
there's no key travel.
It's very,
very shallow,
so it's like a just a tiny movement.
Click,
click,
click.
What I use is I use a think pad and the,
one of the reasons why I use the
thinkpad is there's like travel to these
keys.
These keys have motion to them.
Like if you just your old school.
Yeah.
Well the thing is you feel where the
keys are,
you feel like.
So as you're typing I can just look at
the screen and I don't have to look down
at the keyboard and they depressed with
your fingers.
Yeah,
there's motion to it.
So there's no accidental pressing of the
keys.
Did you take typing in high school?
Yes.
I don't remember any of it though.
Yeah,
me too.
I might have my high school year.
Was it last year that they had typing at
my school?
Really?
Yeah.
I remember they were saying like this is
the longer.
Because they had a computer class that
they were starting.
I just thought,
damn,
like I look back on this things and I
just go,
wow,
how times have changed our generation.
Is this like generation that is like we
went through the first of all of these
things.
I had a commodore 64.
Did you?
Yes,
I remember the first apple laptop.
I remember.
I remember like when games systems
changed and color TV and call waiting
and like all the things that we were,
you know,
their answering machine answering
machine to.
They know,
they know more answering machines and
can even apply in Israel machines nine,
seven,
six numbers and you know,
like all,
all of that stuff was life.
Sex Lines.
Yeah.
Good call.
Like,
Oh God,
I got in trouble one time,
like thank God I was calling a
Christmas,
I was going to call the Christmas one
first and then I was going to call the
sex one and then I called the Christmas
one first and then my mom picks up the
other one and I hang up and then my
mom's like,
Erica,
are you talking to Santa Claus?
Oh Shit.
How old were you at?
Thirteen isn't like that,
you know,
like just getting into your,
so like even just even how we find porn
is different now.
Like it's so like when I'm looking,
I'm thinking about you talking about
just keyboard.
It still has a little bit of old school
too.
It has an old school feel to what you're
saying.
You know you still have a.
anytime somebody is using windows.
I know.
It's like,
oh they're.
They're connected to the past still.
Well,
I just switched over to a reasonably
when I.
I fucked around with a thinkpad one day
and I was like,
wow,
this keyboard is so much better because
I have a Mac book to one of them.
New Mac book pros.
You just,
you just can't handle it.
It's just not a good keyboard.
It's shit.
It's not just bad.
And there's no options.
Like if you want a laptop,
they don't give you options for
keyboard.
Yeah.
You can't customize the now and you can
get a different one.
Like if you want windows,
you can get an a seuss.
You can get,
you can get you a shit ton.
There's get a dell desktop though.
I have an Imac.
You can hook up.
Sure.
Yeah,
with the desktop.
But the problem is,
most of my shit,
I go in the Oh,
third class action lawsuit over Mac
book,
Pro Keyboard,
allegedly fraudulent concealment.
This guy's a research king right here.
Let's see.
But look at that keyboard.
Look how fucking shallow those keys are.
That's bullshit west to keep it thin,
man.
But it doesn't matter.
That's bad for a writer.
If you're a writer,
that's a shitty design.
Remember how thick too?
Yeah.
But make it a little thicker.
Jesus Christ.
Who gives a fuck if it's an extra half a
millimeter,
if you have good keyboard feel.
I mean it depends on what you're doing.
If you're the type of person just writes
an email every now and then,
but I fucking right.
I need a keyboard.
I feel you need it so I could take a
beating too.
Yeah,
I still fuck around with that when I,
you know,
I still have it so I fuck around with
that.
If I,
if I travel,
if I go online,
if I'm just just web surfing,
it's fine for that.
But it sucks a fat one.
When it deals with.
Did you get a text message?
I'm already getting messages about this
and it's just coming to the
phone's gonna like,
but the only time my phone is blowing up
like this before is when the Justin
bieber posted a picture with him.
I'm with you on his instagram and then
my phone was shaking,
shaking for,
for,
for a month straight from
you guys.
Nobody believed me.
Let me turn on their notifications and I
put it down like this and it's just like
I'm talking about daggone thousands of
notifications.
That guy could topple a government if
you really want it to.
Like if it got political,
that's a problem.
That's what we're dealing with with
trump.
A famous person who becomes the
president.
I mean this little kid is only 24,
right?
What the fuck out is?
Even if he didn't mean 24,
just turned 24.
Yeah.
Okay.
Jaymes hate jaymes hate.
It's actually a good kid.
He really is.
But if I gave you one,
if I gave you $100,000,000 and no
parental supervision,
you'd do some dumb shit to do way worse
listening right now.
I would do a lot of dumb shit if you
gave me 100 million dollars just out of
nowhere.
Out of nowhere.
He's done well for what he is,
you know,
the kind of fame that,
that guy possessive.
He's off the charts famous.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
But then some was.
So it was trump.
Trump was super famous,
super,
super famous.
This is why we can't get rid of the
electoral college though by the way.
Not to get political but does help.
But I mean did he rigged that?
But you can't make it but played the
game.
Well,
I can't have a popularity contest,
but it is a popularity contest no matter
what.
Even with the Electoral College,
we just have to be popular in Iowa.
Popular in Ohio know how to do that and
just go over there and talk about
Muslims.
Shake your fist.
Why don't we,
I still don't understand why we don't
just have online voting app or like or
like or with your phone.
Like you have to have a frame and then
you register your phone so that Imi,
he number that your phone has is
strictly for you.
You,
they,
they already
have,
what do you call it?
Like facial recognition software.
You,
their phones have fingerprint.
So there's like three different ways to
like register and then you'll get
everyone's vote.
I always say vote should be like the
Columbia DVD.
How?
Remember Columbia Dvds,
they would just send them just giving it
to you.
So if you're a Republican,
right?
Then your vote goes to the Republican
until you go.
I don't want this from the numbers of
people that people don't know what we're
talking about with Columbia DVD because
we're old.
But back in the day you would sign up
for like cassette tapes and they would
send you a bunch of cassettes.
Like you'd pick.
Go to book club?
Yeah,
that too.
But they would send them to you,
but it was only like a dollar and you'd
get like 15 sets,
you know,
you get like aerosmith and is it still
on?
It's still on but the fuck out and check
it out.
They finally made it so they don't just
send it automatically because people
were.
People were quitting the service.
Yeah,
but they would just send you.
So you would pay and you had like say
three days and if you,
if you didn't send it back,
they would charge you to $9.
Right?
So that's what I'm saying about voting.
This is how we should vote.
Thirty $5 page right there.
He's showing us,
she'd be like all your candidates for
Democrat and if you don't eat them,
have three days to pick.
And if you don't pick your vote goes to
them.
That's how they should do it.
Show me what you just showed me.
What are you doing?
What'd you show them?
Look on the details.
What does it say?
It says it's $35 for like two,
something like that.
Okay.
Free shipping is only eligible for
orders of two.
Have more dvds with a sub total of $35.
Say preorders are not eligible for free
shipping.
Okay.
So they say it's free shipping,
but it's not free shipping.
Is that what they're doing?
And they say it's 95 each.
But free shipping,
that's more than $35 free shipping on
two plus dvds,
but the dvds or nine 95.
So two plus is what for?
Because it has to be more than $35.
You fucking crux.
They're all crooks.
The record companies are so gross,
dude.
I've been talking to people that had
Steven Tyler and here was explaining
what happens now with streaming,
so that was great by the way.
Oh,
thank you.
He's great,
right?
Yeah.
Fascinating.
I mean you want to talk about a guy who
was singing it all.
I'm never surprised when someone like
that with that type of personality.
I'm not surprised that you see the kind
of life and career he's had.
Those people aren't there.
They're a notch above the norm.
Yeah,
he's definitely a notch above the noise.
Super sweet guy too.
Nice to everybody.
Just oh,
hugging everybody.
And really friendly as time of being
like.
I'm sure there was a super dick.
You think so come on to some famous.
You don't get that famous at the time
when people are treating you like just a
god,
you know,
everywhere he went.
I mean rock star,
that was the pinnacle Rockstar.
A list.
So a list actor,
professional athlete.
That's the order,
but do you think they have to be dicks?
No,
no,
no.
Do you think they become dicks?
But just because.
Here's my theory about that is that the
fame,
that level of fame is overwhelming.
People grabbing at you all the time,
so you just develop this dickie thing
just to keep people the fuck away from
you.
Like if you get to that,
I would imagine like that Michael Jordan
or a even bieber mean that there's a
level where you can't go anywhere.
Listen,
I've been.
I've been around Bieber.
Yeah.
What's it like?
He's not an.
He's never alone.
He's always got somebody there.
I don't think he trusts anyone and that
level of fame where you're just also
used to,
you know,
get me a water or get the car.
I want to go here.
When you get used to,
that becomes normal.
Just telling people.
Just telling people what to do becomes
normal.
Listen,
I was at,
I was at a party and he was.
He was there and he's,
he's playing his music for his new album
and he just looks at me and he says,
Hey,
can you give me a,
can you give me a vodka?
He says,
give me a vodka.
And then I went.
I was like,
okay,
you know,
like I was so mad at myself
because I'm over here.
Like,
oh,
I gotta get back.
Excuse me.
Everybody got away.
I got time.
Yeah.
And then when I gave it to him I thought
I should have said no,
fuck if I'm 47 years old,
what the fuck?
He was playing the piano at the same
thing.
I was at the laugh factory and he was
there.
He was watching and the scooter who's a
buddy of mine,
scooter Braun,
scooter comes down,
you know when he says,
Hey Erica,
justin would like to see you.
And I.
At first I was like,
you don't submit a walkway,
you don't summon me,
but of course I was like,
all right,
let's go.
I went and then like,
and then I saw him too and I was like,
I realized like,
because I'm a nerd this way,
I mean I'm a fan of all types of music,
so I'm not.
I think the kids dynamic I think is very
talented.
I don't think it's a surprise that he's
just famous,
you know what I mean?
People get on him just by the way in
defensive bieber real fast.
You can't tell somebody they're great
since they're eight years old,
eight years old.
You're great,
you're great when these nine,
you're great.
When he's 10,
When he's 11,
you're great.
Think about that.
Then that 13 is probably when he first
went,
well,
am I putting,
you know,
and then 15 it was like,
I'm not great.
I am great at 18.
Fucking great now.
And then when,
when he finally says it,
then that's when everybody goes,
whoa Bro.
Tony down.
It's too late.
The monsters already been let loose.
Well,
he's already mature,
right?
He's already become a,
an actual adult and he probably has no
come left in his body at any given time.
Swinton low dude all day long.
It's just recovery time for him.
He's got.
If he tweeted,
I need some pussy tonight.
Oh,
it's out of control.
It would be like American idol auditions
would be crazy than that.
If you've seen that.
A Guatemalan volcano eruption,
have you seen
people are running from the smog?
It's fucking crazy girls guys.
It wouldn't be that much pussy coming
down the mountain headed towards you.
It's that Guatemala eruption is fucking
scary,
man.
There's nothing like that in comedy
other than Chris Delea.
Yeah,
he's close.
He's close,
but even looking at this Guatemala,
most violent eruption in more than 100
years.
Twenty five people already dead and just
think it just happened yesterday.
It's fucking crazy,
man.
People have died after interrupted.
Yeah.
Sunday is getting back at us.
Dude.
That's two right?
Hawaii and this one.
I mean we've got to be real fucking
careful.
Surprise.
New Zealand hasn't had a couple of
options.
Did they have like a live volcano in New
Zealand?
I just know that I think.
Can you fact check this,
but I think New Zealand has the most
volcanoes in the world.
What?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I was just the air tours and they're
like,
you know,
what'd you do over there?
Well,
I went to the Cook Islands.
Woo.
Captain Cook.
I Cook Islands.
Man Pirates showed up.
Beautiful vacation and there's no
Americans,
which is what I love you.
I can't get.
I can't stand going someplace and it's
just all American.
Like I don't go to Ensonata.
You know,
you go to Venice beach know I don't want
to be around the same time.
Now.
He is.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm like going to a one hour is
basically beverly hills.
Beverly Hills Water Volcano.
Map of New Zealand.
Jesus Christ.
See?
Oh,
he's fucking four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
Volcanoes that.
Right?
Like,
you can't lie on this show because this
guy's going to fact check you right
away.
Yeah,
it is insane.
But I'm telling you right now,
beautiful vacation.
Oh,
I bet.
I didn't like actually,
like do Zealand,
like I went to Oakland,
I thought I'm driving around downtown
La.
Oh,
like cs or something?
I didn't like to sit down.
I'm not a city guy.
I liked this kind of Shit,
like outdoors nature of beaches.
Yeah.
Well the nature there is stunning.
I want to look out my hotel window when
the sliding door and like there's sand
and then like the water's like right
there or mountains.
Yeah,
he exact something.
Rain forest,
something,
something.
Something that's different from this
urban jungle that we live in all the
time.
You have been in Costa Rica?
I have been.
God just went to Costa Rica with my
girlfriend.
We just started to get together and it
was,
it was good to get together.
Yeah,
we were close to Rico.
Yeah.
Well I mean we,
I mean it was,
it was,
it was too soon or how long were you
guys dating?
It was too soon.
I thought maybe we'd be like four or
five months,
you know,
but it was like Christmas time and I'm
with her.
I'm like,
let me make this special.
So we go to Costa Rica,
you know,
I do it up and she went to Christian and
with you and not the family.
Yeah.
Well she's Jewish,
so.
Oh,
there you go.
They're all monsters.
Dare you gotta be careful with that kind
of time.
People,
their career is over.
No,
I'm just teasing about girls.
But girlfriend's Jewish had a beautiful
family.
So,
uh,
she was like,
well,
I don't care about Christmas anyway,
so let's go.
Don't go see my mom who moved to my
parents.
Just moved to Malaga.
Where's that?
In Spain.
Oh,
they moved to like the southern tip of
Spain,
you know,
because they went on a cruise one day,
stopped in Malaga,
and then my mom's like,
we got to come back here.
Cost of living is so low that they're
living like kings over there,
like a great two bedroom condo with like
a Malibu type view.
600 euro a month.
Why?
Yeah.
Dude,
it's,
I'm telling you right now,
you got to look up the cost of living in
Spain.
It's crazy.
A lot of people from Britain,
they retire in Spain because our money
goes a lot further.
Oh,
I've heard that.
I've heard that people go there to avoid
taxes from France.
Yeah.
It's a lot of stuff,
man.
So I take.
So we go to Costa Rica and it was fine.
It was great.
It was one of these resorts where like,
you could get room service 24 hours or
do what you want.
It's all covered in the thing.
But I got sick Joe.
Oh No,
I knew it was high or Maria sec or what
kind of said it was every hole in my
body,
something was coming out of it.
Okay.
And then I was in bed.
I was telling.
I said I don't,
I don't feel good.
And I met.
And then as a comic I'm making it.
I made a joke at her that she didn't
appreciate.
She was mad at me about this joke.
So at I'm also telling her like,
look,
I'm not feeling well.
And then it happened.
I get up and I have to vomit.
And then there was nothing.
I vomited in my hands.
I will run to the bathroom and then it's
just like,
it's coming out of both holes
and this is going on for all night.
I'm just,
I'm,
I'm dead.
And the way she was acting,
oh my God,
she was shocked.
She was like,
you're ruining the trend.
So at the time I was like,
Ooh,
well we weren't as close as we are now.
We've,
we've since resolved the issue and.
But at the time I was like,
I can't be with somebody that's not
gonna look.
Right.
She ordered room service while I was
already writing it off.
Yeah.
Just,
well I'm going to go ahead and get a
fucking cheeseburger.
Then that was making me more sick.
The food smell.
So I'm.
So I'm outside.
But then she was like,
I was mad at you for your jokes and
like,
you know,
I always,
I always tell her,
she goes,
she said to me one day,
you know,
my brothers,
they used to tease me all the time when
I was growing up that I said,
why don't you get with a comic?
Yeah.
Something's going on.
If you know how we say we get with our
mother,
you know,
or,
whatever the qualities are.
So I think whatever,
whatever you're close to in your life
though,
she's accustomed to people giving her a
hard time.
Know she didn't like it.
She went with him,
so I'm,
I'm,
we're trying to balance it out,
you know,
there's got to be compromised.
You got to meet,
you know what I mean?
If she's here and you're here,
you got to go into this ever is when you
just start dating someone and you go on
a vacation with them and it goes sour
and you're stuck with them for like five
days in some spot and it usually happens
by the way on the plane ride over.
There's something that happens on the
plane where you're like,
oh,
I don't like you and we're going to be
on this plane for six more hours and
then you know,
you're going to get to this hotel.
I mean,
yes.
What you have to be compatible with
somebody before you travel.
Make.
Oh yeah.
You have to make sure,
like,
think even things like I like,
I want to go out and do things.
Maybe if you're outdoorsy person and you
want to like leave the hotel or maybe
you're not,
maybe you're a person that wants to take
advantage of everything in the hotel or
you're on vacation and you want to
chill.
That has to be established or you're
going to be in a situation where you're
like,
what do we still do it in the hotel or
the other person's like,
I don't want to go.
Why are we going out?
I like Migraine and the
Migraine and so and then fall asleep and
you hear the way we survived though.
We survived it.
You know we made you change your phone
though.
Was fucked up.
I know that was the cops.
Soon as it's over.
Well,
so back to say I'm going to be the
Andrea.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's going to be over.
We're coming up on a year.
Who?
Shit?
Yeah.
We're coming up on A.
Yeah,
but I hear people.
You know what it is is people like you.
It's your fucking fault.
He can work.
You're on stage talking about your great
family and you want a family and how you
deal with it.
Yeah.
You think about these things,
man.
How old do you know?
I'm 46.
So thinking about shooting live ones in
there and make them.
I'm thinking about like,
you know what?
Maybe it's time.
You know what it is is like once I,
I've,
I'm not super successful,
but I've enjoyed my career and now I'm
like,
oh,
I enjoy this.
I'm going to share this with someone
that really cares about me and I.
and one thing I'll say for a,
she,
I feel the love you.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
I really do feel the love.
She's a very loving woman,
a very beautiful.
And so she got used to you after awhile
and understands your jokingness and
appreciates you coming.
You're a good guy.
I'll tell you something that she did
that.
This is why I'm even talking about her
right now.
So she moved me.
Joe The other day we were having a like
a little fight,
low fi,
a little fight and then it was obviously
I was like,
we're not communicating.
I told her,
you know what she did,
she downloaded communicating with your
man audio book and she and we sat and
listened to it together and it was like,
that's why I quit when checking,
check this check.
That changed my phone number through my
phone in the ocean.
Like it was like,
it was like the guy that wrote the book
was talking about her.
That was the best part about it.
He was like,
it would be like something like,
you know,
what you shouldn't do with your man is
don't have a look on your face of
disgust when you,
when you're mad.
It was like all these things.
And then there was one moment I'm going
like this.
I had my hands in the air and it was
like,
if your man's body language,
if he has his hands,
that's your time to back off.
And I was like this,
did you date this guy because he's
talking about you right now.
You know what I mean?
But I thought that the gesture of being
like,
Hey,
I need to improve.
I need to like change how I feel or,
or like,
you know,
maybe look at a self self reflect that,
the act of that self reflection with her
that that was,
that's big speak volumes for her and her
character and it really made me go,
okay,
you really want to,
you want to make this work and that's
awesome.
Yeah.
So I said,
okay,
I want to make it work.
How old is she?
Twenty nine.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
So she's at that age,
should not have said that.
I know.
That's good.
So much trouble.
Why not supposed to tell?
I'm not supposed to tell her like she,
she want.
Oh God.
Well the cat's out the bag now.
So fucking write their name.
Just go to my instagram.
You're going to say,
oh my God,
I'm so sorry.
I know.
I know,
but that's part of the problem,
you know what I mean?
But.
No,
but she know because she,
she doesn't want people to know.
So she wants,
she wants people to know.
She thinks she's 23.
So I.
So I said,
hey,
that,
that makes me look like a creeper
creeper.
And even this age difference is a little
Iffy,
right?
So like it's weird how we just make
rules as to how old someone can be to be
with someone else.
But it changes after a while.
Right?
Like,
once you get,
like,
if the dude is like this guy,
he and the woman's 50,
we don't go give a fuck,
whatever.
No,
no,
no.
I would say to me it's like it's gotta
be 30,
like you know,
like she's at the cusp of it.
I think like once a woman gets to like
28,
29,
30 in that age range,
then this other part,
it doesn't matter it depending on what
they got going on in their life.
But it's not about the age,
it's about experience level.
It's about where are you in your life.
So at the moment,
one thing I struggle with is that like,
look,
I'm knee deep in my career when I
remember when I was 30,
I wasn't doing this.
I was,
I just started.
You were hustling.
I was hustling.
So I go,
I have to remember that this is her
hustle years.
So you started doing standup at 30?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I took a late start,
right?
I started,
I went to a comedy class when I was in
my early twenties because my mom,
one of those supportive women.
I said,
hey mom,
I think I want to be a comedian next
day.
I'm signed up at La at Ucla extension,
you know,
with a notebook.
And she's like,
yeah,
that's all my mom.
If I said I want to be a rock,
if I said I want to be a rock climber.
And my mom was like,
okay.
She goes,
she would've bought ropes and like hook
me up with the because you want to be
out of the fucking house,
you know,
like when I was young,
you know.
So I went to the class taught by sandy
shore.
Oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
It was,
I thought it.
I thought this is going to be it.
Her mom,
daughter,
her mom owns the comedy store.
I'm going to make it.
That was the advice.
Look at you.
Wow.
This,
this motherfucker right here.
Joe Rogan tried to start.
She's me.
How good was the advice?
I misspoke.
And I can't tell you this,
this is,
I really,
I,
I need it.
I suggest to anyone if you want to be a
comic,
go to one comedy class just for the
comfort of the environment and the
support to go to one comedy class.
But after that you got to get out there
into the open mics and you got to do it
on your own.
But I suggest one comedy class.
All right.
There's nothing wrong with it.
So I went and I loved that.
And then by the way,
the Od,
the showcase for the graduation was at
the comedy store in the or.
So the first time I ever did standup
comedy within the or at the comedy store
was this,
it was like 90 something to 93.
And you know what I remember
specifically,
it was like after our show,
they just rolled into the,
our show first got onstage Carlos
Mitzia.
Wow.
And he goes on and at the time he was
like,
you know,
Oh,
just at that
time he was like,
Taco Bell.
That is fucking hilarious.
I remember watching him and I'm at the
time,
at the time,
I remember watching him thinking,
I think I can do this,
you know,
because I had a great set.
I had a great first set,
you know,
you know how that goes and supportive
people in the crowd.
And um,
you know,
I have my funny hacky jokes that I was
doing at the time.
Just my knew what I thought was new.
I remember one of my jokes was like,
I was like,
how come you can't recognize superman?
And then I would take my glasses off,
you know,
like I'd be like,
look,
I'm Clark Kent,
take them off man.
You know,
that was like,
I thought that was hilarious at the
time.
Um,
no black people on jeopardy.
That was another one of my jokes.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
So I had like a had black categories on
jeopardy already,
you know,
blind singers,
barbecue holidays,
you know,
I had,
I was killing back then with that shit,
man.
So brutal though.
When you go to a real show with that
shit and it's crickets,
but you're like,
but an open mic night.
It's weird,
right?
Like there's open mic night material
where it does okay on open mic nights
and you're like,
this is some good material.
I just got to develop it.
I don't even think it's even open mic.
I think even worse is doing it in front
of a crowd,
you know,
this is what happens to get side
tracked,
but I love it.
You know when you're.
When you go in the Middle American when
you first were coming up when you were
still a major headliner and then like
the local guy will be there that local
guys now going to be on Joe Rogan's show
in Iowa and he's going to be performing
in front of two or 300 people.
Right?
That type of hacky material is going to
kill with those people.
Then then that person now thinks that
this is how you do it and they bring
that to La and New York and then they're
like,
oh,
how come this isn't working?
And then they're seeing like a thousand
other comics doing,
you know,
talking about the same subjects and then
they don't realize how they had to find
some originality.
And what they're doing,
and that's the hard part.
That's the hard part.
We,
there's not a lot of subjects to talk
about,
you know,
you're not the first comment to get
married and have daughters.
Right.
But this experience that you had is,
is it is personal to you and conveying
that is the hard part,
right?
You know,
and so people kind of go just surface
which are material.
It's hard to delve deeper and it's hard.
It's hard to have the confidence to drag
a subject out too.
Like when you first start out like you,
your premises are so short and then you
go from one short premise to another
short premise and then it becomes a,
it becomes a bit,
the bit becomes a,
you know,
a set then.
And then now you're talking about often
tell comics like that.
It's like music,
you know,
if you heard,
uh,
if you heard like a Neptune's beat,
you can hear it from a mile away.
You can know when you hear it you go,
Oh,
I bet you the neptunes produce that
track.
Or,
or premier,
you know,
the Dj Premier,
he would produce a beat and you'd be
like,
oh,
that's a premier beat.
Your comic.
Your comedy is the same way when you're
working on things.
You work on it in your way that if you
looked at all your material,
you might now see the common thread and
that's how you put together an act.
Thirty minutes,
40 minutes.
That's how you're able to talk about a
subject for so long because we've now
woven together these thoughts that we
don't think are connected,
but when we look at them,
you go,
oh,
which I'm actually.
This subject actually flows into this
and it connects very nicely so that
that's what was going on.
So I'm watching again.
I'm watching Lexia at the time.
I'm just a young kid.
I don't know what to do next.
I just had a great set I thought,
and now I'm looking at these
professionals and I saw them and see it
and at that particular time I was like,
I saw him and when he talked about Taco
bell and stuff,
I thought,
you know,
I think I could do this.
You know,
and then he brought up Chris Tucker and
Chris Tucker went on stage and I was
thought to myself,
I don't think I could do this just the
way he was.
So like,
what is voice man?
You know,
just just Taco tacos on fire back then.
Yeah,
just uh,
his whole persona and I thought I didn't
know and I didn't know what to do.
So I floundered around.
I did open minded.
You get nervous when you saw Chris
Tucker?
I do so powerful.
It was just so it was something special
about what he was doing and I just
thought,
I don't know if I don't.
I just was scattered to habit at that
time,
man.
I was so nervous and scared and arrogant
too because I was a funny guy.
So then I would go to open mics and then
the same people doing the same shit over
and over and over again.
Then I wouldn't go to another open mic
for another four weeks and then I see
the same people and I thought,
well,
how do you get from here?
How do you get on the,
you know,
this and know it and I didn't know.
There was no mentors,
there was no people going like,
let me help you with this.
You know,
you couldn't even talk to someone of
your stature at all.
Like,
you know,
at the time you couldn't just be some
open micro and I,
by the way,
they shouldn't do that.
You know what I mean?
Like you know,
you don't need the comedy store and some
dude comes up to you.
You're just kinda like,
what do you want to talk to me about
right now?
Dude.
Like you just started kyle approach I
think especially when they worked there
as door guys.
I feel like everybody's just a comic
that's different,
that's different.
But like there's,
there's a sorta but even still like it's
like,
I don't know if it's so appropriate for
a door guy to come up to you and be
like,
Yo,
can I open for you at Irvine?
You know,
some guy just did that the other day.
Mitch,
I don't know you.
I don't know.
You know,
I have friends by the way.
I used to do that.
They show.
Yeah,
I used to do that.
I remember John,
Johnny Sanchez.
Sure.
First was coming up.
I went to Johnson.
Johnny,
let me open for you.
I'm a jug or not.
Is that what you said?
I told them I was agenda.
I said I'm trying to bury these
headliners,
man.
That's what I was trying to.
I thought that's what she told him.
Yeah,
that's what you thought you were
supposed to do.
I was like checking his watch.
Oh,
look at the time.
So He's,
he's teased me ever since.
This is a 22 year old,
15 years later he still teases me about
it.
But um,
you know,
so I,
I didn't know.
I didn't know what I was doing,
you know,
I didn't know how to.
Well,
what are you supposed to do,
man?
Now there's no clear path.
It's not just being a doctor.
There's no right or wrong way either,
you know?
I didn't know.
It's true too.
Especially I grew up in La.
I was born and raised in La,
so I'm in La trying to get on a stage
where I would go to the law.
Like I was telling you earlier,
I saw you at the laugh factory with
hair,
you know,
and just like a man you were on stage,
like I'm not like you were just given
it.
There's a certain energy you had about
what you were talking about that I was
like,
damn,
what happened to this guy?
Like I remember the first thought,
I was like,
man,
some woman hurt him
and I thought,
I don't know if I've tapped into that
yet.
I thought at the time,
I don't know if I've tapped into that.
So it took a long time for me to
realize,
oh no,
this is what I want to do.
And like when I was 13,
he's different,
you know,
like some people go up there and they're
excited and angry about shit and some
people go up there and they're mellow.
And that's the funny part is the slow,
low punchlines,
you know.
But even if you like sigora perfect
exact,
just could tell a story.
Have you captivated?
Yeah,
there's no anger,
there's no,
no,
like screaming emotions.
Cigarettes just chill out.
But don't you find yourself?
Have you ever gone,
gone up?
It had been in because you have a way of
performing,
like you know you have a,
you know,
as Joe Mode,
you're on there,
it's going to be powerful and you're
gonna you're like really?
And then have you ever just gone on and
Kinda like not done it that way,
but then now you get laughed at a
completely different point and you're
set with new material for sure because
you're trying to find the,
you know,
you trying to find the beats.
I,
I set material up to fail sometimes,
like I'll go into a bit slower and I'll
go and do a bit more casual and try to
ramp it up rather than try to make it
like sometimes when you get a new bit,
especially when you first started out
like this bit is shaky,
let me just get it out of the gate with
a lot of momentum so that I can kind of
coast with it.
Sometimes I'll,
I'll say,
all right,
well this bit might be all just bullshit
or what Tom Calls Thompson [inaudible]
calls them dance moves.
I used to call it English,
English on the cue ball because
sometimes you're just,
you're hamming it up,
you're doing that.
What you're saying,
you doing that thing that you do that.
No.
Makes people laugh and it's really
difficult,
isn't it?
It's really difficult for me because I'm
just a funny looking guy,
you know?
I mean,
I accepted it,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not a looker,
you know what I mean?
I'm cute.
You know what I'm saying?
I had some felony guy mustache works
with,
you know my qualities.
Right.
But I know that like that I could do a
thing that they're thinking,
why are they laughing at what I'm
talking about?
Like are they with me emotionally?
Are they with me intellectually or are
they just going like,
oh,
this guy is funny and it's hard to
recognize that.
Yeah.
Right.
Like,
what do you want from them?
Do you want to.
Do you want to connect with them?
Do you want them to laugh?
Do you want both or do you want them to
appreciate you,
they just,
you just want them to have a good time
or do you even want them to laugh at how
you are connected to what you're talking
about?
Because that's different too.
Like if you're a political comic,
people might laugh that like how
passionate you are about being a
libertarian or how passionate you are
about being an atheist.
Maybe they don't agree with you or maybe
they do agree with you,
but they just,
they're laughing at how you are
connected to what you're saying.
And I think that that's another element
that's.
And that's a whole other thing.
You know,
I look at all my friends,
uh,
you know,
we have a lot of peers or friends that
we just go,
like,
they all have something different in
that way.
Yeah.
You know,
in the summer it's an,
it's an amazing thing to watch.
It's a crazy art form because nobody can
tell you how to do it.
Sounded like any other art form.
Yeah.
It really know like if you went into
music or I went into music like we
could,
like you can be in a rock band or you
could be in a blues band or you get like
country music and everybody would be
clearly defined,
but you just do standup.
Yeah.
It's just standup.
I mean there's no,
there's no categories.
What was funny about that though is I
know that there's no categories,
but I do think that it is similar to
music in that we're not going to change
the rules of communication and I think
that's where people get in the way.
So like when you're on a piano,
you're not going to make new cords.
It's still going to be a,
b,
c,
d,
g,
you know what I mean?
And like the certain courts when they go
together or not gonna sound good no
matter what,
you're not going to reinvent the wheel.
So I think the baseline of comedy is
like just being able to communicate your
points and I think one of your,
a person that can communicate your
points and they're solid and clear.
Then the jokes on top of that or going
to what the entertainment is going to
be,
but you know,
you still got to like you don't want
somebody says they're telling the story
and nobody says anything and then they
go,
well,
you know you had to be there.
Well that's a horrible storyteller.
That's,
that's what that is.
You'll never hear Joey Dsa that never
be their cock sucker.
Like that would be like,
well I don't know if I want to be there
bro.
You know you had to be there means you
failed in communicating.
So I think that on that level,
even though all comics are different in
it's weird,
but that level of like long when.
So when you say setup,
that is important.
It's not going to be universal to all of
us.
You have to set this up.
Yeah.
That's the case with all songs and
everything too.
But their styles,
you know,
like there's certain styles of comedy.
Yeah.
I guess their styles of comedy so much.
There's no distinct style.
If you heard like
for example,
a Hank Williams Jr,
like,
well,
that's clearly country and you just hear
it,
you know right away you hear,
yeah,
there's some wacky about country.
There's something about the story.
I love country with a good story.
You know,
driving down a highway,
you know,
whatever you do is healing a couple of
words.
I know what the fuck this is.
Just to have like music behind it.
You know what he sat your comedy at the
time it was the country music of comedy.
I think you misrepresenting
never.
It was a story.
You know you,
you felt that the anguish.
I don't think that's what I was doing.
Are you trying to look back and think
weird though?
He had hair.
It was a whole different guy.
Yeah.
No,
you weren't this.
You're a solid muscle now.
Like I don't know if you have.
What's your body fat count right now?
I don't get it checked.
Okay.
That's probably better.
It's probably better to think that it's
better than it probably is.
I think if you went and you might be
disappointed.
The last time I checked it was 10
percent.
Oh my gosh.
Not very low.
I'm probably like 30 percent,
35 percent body fat.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I got stumped in.
That's not good.
But I,
you know what it is.
I,
I my but my blood pressure's good.
That's good.
Yeah.
Because I,
you know,
I,
I told him you what I'm trying to box
man.
I'm working out.
I went to this,
I'm going to the boxing thing and it's
like I go to glove works,
works in century city and shit.
Yeah,
it's a pads holding,
holding the thing in.
And this something that tricks you with
that though,
because they hit them back.
Yeah.
So youth in um,
after I've done it a few times,
I'm walking around in public like,
Fucker,
I wish,
I wish somebody would test me like
they're going to hold up their hands and
fight me like this,
but you know,
what's something about going to boxing
is changed my perception of women,
women in the boxing thing.
Like they really at that shit is when
you see a,
you know,
I'm working out with five people and
then a woman goes in and he goes on,
you know,
and she's like,
I'm just like,
God damn,
this is good,
this is great.
I was like,
you can handle yourself all my
preconceived notions of like,
and it's something stupid,
a stupid male thing is to see a woman
fighting.
And then the first thought is,
Oh yeah,
somebody hurt her.
You know.
You got a lot of that in you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That was me.
I know I had this people.
Everybody's hurting when.
Oh God,
this is,
this is like therapy.
It's coming out.
Yeah.
Maybe I was hurt.
Maybe you needed a cassette
sets.
I do.
I'm working on it,
man.
I just did your oldest fuck kids that
they're going like,
what is that?
They don't even know what a CD is.
A laser disc.
You little fuck.
Yeah.
What is this?
But the boxing has been cool.
I like a fun workout and you know,
women are weird though.
It is weird.
Somebody sent me a picture of this,
a mma chick and she was a,
there's this woman who's down and she's
a,
I don't know who the lady is,
I'm not familiar with our shells and
fight in the UFC,
but she's got blood on her and she's
going like this and she standing up over
this chick,
she's pounding,
she's like this,
and I'm like,
damn,
that is an angry woman.
I can't do those kinds of.
I can't,
I don't like male UFC.
I don't leave.
I just too violent for me.
I just live,
you know,
do you want to go?
I would go and I was watching the other
day because I heard your voice just one
in La in August.
I want to go.
I want to go because it just seems so
like very,
you know,
it is that,
by the way,
I find it like I,
I don't like watching women hit each
other,
you know?
I just don't like it.
I don't know,
maybe that's my male thing,
you know?
But I think that like how can we be in a
society where we're talking about no
violence against women?
What?
Unless it's paperview like,
no,
no violence against women by men is
okay.
Joe,
let me ask you some violence against
women competition.
Do you think that that woman that beat
up Rhonda Rousey,
Amanda Nunez,
do you think that I fight better than
her?
No.
She'll fuck you up.
She will fuck me up.
That's Amanda Nunez.
Okay.
But if I hit one arousing into face,
he liked her and I go out on a date.
We have something happens.
We have a scuffle and it gets on video
that I punched Ronda Rousey gonna face.
I'm now a pariah is society for the rest
of my life,
but this,
this woman who trains and it's like a
beast
will beat her up.
I just,
I can't get the disconnect.
I can't.
There's not a disconnect.
It's competition sport.
So I don't understand what.
What were you missing?
The connection.
There's such a big difference between
Eric Griffin.
First of all,
ron ain't going on a date with you.
Let's be honest.
You don't know what.
First of all,
how did Travis Brown and he's a fucking
killer.
Okay,
well maybe they have another batch.
Heavyweight.
UFC it so they have a tough patch that
we're going out to get something good.
I'm done.
I need to be some strange.
And she went to the comedy store if I'm
tired of being with a killer,
you know,
she wants somebody cuddly,
soft,
soft and squishy,
and then we'd go out on a date.
No,
you want a punching her because she
fucked.
Does that ever happen?
I don't know.
Maybe.
Have you ever punched anybody in your
life?
A girl?
No,
that's not what I was into.
Sixth grade.
I think I had a fight with a girl one
time and that's the first time I learned
you're not supposed to hit a girl.
Oh,
she was the,
she was a bully.
She was a bully and she was pushing
people and active and she did something
to me and I punched her and then no
matter what she did the whole yard when
you know,
like you don't hit a girl.
And I was like,
oh,
but remember everybody hated her like a
second ago.
Then all of a sudden,
so I knew at that point was outside.
Oh,
you can't do that.
I knew,
I knew that there's some kind of
difference.
I learned it then.
Yeah,
that's a good way to learn it before it
gets ugly before we get.
Sadly,
that was still a little kid.
Yeah.
It was like,
it was probably younger than that to
break anybody's job.
Right,
right,
right.
And in what?
Piss me off too,
she,
I'll never forget this is so vivid in my
head that she admitted immediately went
from bully strong,
like I've run this court yard too.
And I was like,
bitch.
I was like,
what just happened?
You ever want to look her up?
Yeah,
I know.
Just what the fuck she's done to her
disaster of a life.
It was condoleeza rice actually don't
care.
What if it was somebody like that?
That would be crazy.
She's angry at you for punching her all
this time.
Starting wars in Syria and shit.
But I'm saying it could happen.
I'm with Ron.
Let's go back to the difference between
you punch and Rhonda is that would be
the last punch you ever through.
Flip you on your head,
on the concrete.
Smash your head open,
stomp you into a mud puddle and all this
on video all day would say is Erik
Griffin.
It's a woman
or he had a comment.
Yeah,
right,
right.
Domestic abusers.
Strong woman.
I don't mean that in.
Rhonda is a professional mixed martial
arts champion.
She was a champion and one of the
greatest female champions of all time.
I didn't like seeing her face look like
she shouldn't have fought that woman.
I just,
I didn't like seeing it.
I guess what I'm saying there was I
couldn't.
I didn't feel any of that.
I didn't feel any of like,
oh,
it's the competition that she trains
know what I saw is a bruised and
battered woman.
That's what I saw and that's probably my
problem.
You must be talking about the Holly Holm
fight because that's when the one she
was about it.
Yeah.
That's when she got head kick and she
was bloody and it was a 48 seconds of
knuckles in the face.
That was a quick fight.
She just got the fuck beat out of her in
that fight,
but fights anymore.
But there's lessons in that.
See,
you can fight in mma and there's,
there's danger and there's consequences,
but if you're in shape and you're
prepared correctly,
you can fight,
but there's a lot of women that weren't
prepared correctly and Rhonda Fuck them
up.
That's just how it goes.
Let me.
Sometimes there's a name of.
So like sometimes you're the hammer,
sometimes you're the nail is also hot.
Pumped her up,
you know,
it was like,
it was a money marketing.
It was great marketing too.
She only hit me.
I pumped her up,
me doing a lot of the.
But it was based on what she'd been able
to accomplish.
It wasn't based on bullshit.
It was based on her actual performance
inside the octagon against people like
cats and gone,
oh,
against people like Sarah Mcmahon.
I mean,
which she had done was supremely
impressive.
But we love a champion.
We love undefeated.
We love being the best ever we we'd get
behind that.
Right.
And that's what was behind her going
into that fight.
Right.
And it didn't look like that.
That shouldn't have been behind her
going into that fight.
Maybe the Holly Holm fight,
Holly Holm funded even the Holly Holm
fight.
She was under massive amounts of
distractions.
She was under.
She was.
They were at.
They were going to do roadhouse.
Remember they're going to do a roadhouse
movie.
She's having meetings with agents and
they just thought she could fuck up
anybody on the planet.
That's what I'm saying.
The problem is in less didn't look like
a hundred percent.
All in with your training and your
learning and your development,
you're making sure that you've got the
training partners and the right coaching
and the right staff and nutrition and
all these different things.
If you don't,
if you have any,
any part of that missing,
then the people coming up who have all
those bases covered,
they're going to surpass.
You are talented too,
and that's what happened with her.
You're knee deep in the world.
You know everything about it.
Okay.
As a lay person,
just looking at them standing next to
each other.
I was like,
oh,
she gonna get her ass beat.
So you looking at Rhonda standing next
to Holly Holm to Ronda was going to get
harassed.
But yes,
I,
when I saw it,
I was like,
how's this going to work?
Why did you think the,
I don't know,
but just the eye test.
She just looked.
Holly,
Gary,
physically,
she looked bigger.
She was at.
She was physically bigger than this
person.
Seen Sarah Mcmahon.
No,
Rhonda stops Sara Mcmahon in one round.
Sarah Mcmahon was an Olympic silver
medalist and wrestling and she's a tank.
I wasn't into it like that.
Maybe if I'd seen that I would've been
like,
well this is going to be a good fight.
But that was my first time and I just
looking at it,
I was like,
this doesn't look like this is going to
be a good fight.
That's just know.
It just,
I just didn't.
I just didn't think it was going to be a
good fight.
And then when did you hear just you hear
you guys talking,
you hear like,
the guy's going to get all that Holly
Holmes,
she's a box or in this and that.
And I'm like,
Oh wow,
this isn't gonna go well.
And then sure enough it didn't go well.
So then that made me have the respect
level for female,
you know,
fighting if I'm just coming in,
like at that time,
you know,
it was like Ronda Rousey's everywhere.
She's in movies,
she's in like,
you know,
and then you're like,
oh wow,
this is the greatest fighter ever right
here.
This is the chief's,
the,
the attraction of a lifetime.
And then you go,
okay,
I'm gonna,
check it out.
Let me check out.
Wow,
that girl looks big.
I don't think this is going to.
And then she gets demolished and you're
like,
well,
is this a sport?
I think that was a big blow for female
fighting.
What are you talking about?
There was like one of the best things to
ever happen to feminist finding.
Okay,
well we're different in that way.
I think she should have one,
would've been the best thing.
No,
no,
no.
It's good to know that anyone can lose.
Even the greats,
even the greats,
they get it.
We get paired to boxing too much is what
it is.
Boxing has gotta be you gotta be
undefeated,
you know,
boxing.
We love undefeated.
One blemish on your record and it does
something.
It doesn't work like that in MMA.
Right,
right,
right.
Because in mma there's so many different
ways to win.
The only one is really undefeated at the
top of the food chain is.
Well,
two guys,
Khabib,
neuroma Madoff,
who was the lightweight champion.
He's undefeated period.
Mauled everybody except l I acquainted
went the distance with them and you
know,
but still beat his ass.
Still beat him,
but John Jones is really undefeated.
Jon Jones has one loss in his career,
but it's a disqualification.
Is he the guy that's been disqualified
because he was well dogs or something
got caught with some shit in his system
that he shouldn't have had in the system
and how did he get into it in the
system?
We don't know.
It was only in there for a very short
amount of time.
There's a lot of speculation.
We don't until that gets ironed out.
By the way,
one of my good friends in the whole wide
world is Eric Koch.
He's also a UFC MMA fighter.
You Know Eric Koch from two cruises as a
Gen.
Yeah,
Eric.
He's a good buddy.
We played.
You know how I know him?
We play video games together.
Oh,
no shit.
Yeah,
yeah.
We've a motherfucker.
He really is.
He's,
he's
a crazy dude.
Now I know that if I'm in public and
some shit is about to go down.
I checked people's ears.
Oh,
that's a good move.
Yeah.
But sometimes his ear look.
Yeah,
but some bees out there that we're
guards.
Yeah,
but no,
but I'm saying I'm not gonna fight
anyway.
I know,
but don't.
It's one more year of boxing.
I might.
I might be like,
you don't want me doing that pattern.
Started thinking.
Yeah man,
listen,
that noise I'm making.
No,
dude.
Can I tell you one quick.
The first time I ever boxed,
I was like,
uh,
I went with Craig Robinson on cracker
box at each other.
Know we weren't boxing each other,
but Craig was starting to box and he
took me to the gym and it was this old
black dude.
He was like in his sixties,
right?
Old School black.
So I got into the ring with him.
The Guy,
he was like,
hi,
come on.
In the ring,
you know,
so I'm in there and we're boxing he
three minutes,
I have so much more respect for boxers
after doing this.
So he's like,
Yo,
keep your hands up,
you know,
and I'm like,
alright.
And then he hit me in the head.
Joe didn't keep your head up and I was
like,
after he hit me twice,
something locks in man get angry and
then it was like 30 seconds left in the
fight and he put his hands up.
He was like,
finished the fight like you own the
street.
Don't understand.
Finally drawn and street.
And I kicked him in the nuts.
I went like sales off.
I went like this
box again for a little while until
recently.
So that was one time.
It was once.
It was so hard.
It was like that three minutes.
I was like,
how can these people throw 50 punches?
Well you got to build up to it,
Eric.
I'm going to man to come here.
I need to.
I want to know what I need to work out.
He's laughing.
He's laughing like you can't deal with
the Joe Rogan workout.
The key is to do a workout top.
I thought about doing one a while ago,
but
I'd read this.
I do too many things publicly.
I'd rather just keep someone's to just
myself.
This is a man who has a family now has,
has reached a level of success that he
is comfortable and now you're starting
to see like not everyone needs to know
everything.
It's not just that there's value in
doing things just for you.
Not.
No,
no,
no.
Just working on stuff and doing things
just for you.
Don't do things publicly.
Agree.
In this day and age,
everybody does everything on social
media and I've done a bunch of things,
put them on social media,
but I think there's real.
There's benefit like why did you do the
things you do?
Well,
I do the things I do for two reasons.
One,
either I enjoy them or I think they make
me better.
They make me a better person.
Like it all.
Be on your tape.
I do a lot of yoga.
I did yoga today and I do it.
I do it a lot and one of the reasons why
I do it,
I think it makes me a better person.
I think it makes me more mellow,
which I think is good.
I have a tendency to not be mo mellow.
It makes me more friendly.
I think it calms me down and I think
it's very good for my body,
so I do it all the time,
but I'm not about to do some fucking
yoga video.
I think I do stand up for that reason.
Yoga calm.
He calms you down.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
I do stand up to like,
yeah,
it did.
It does.
It calms me down.
If something happens to me,
I go directly to the stage.
That's a great way to work on it though.
Like can develop material.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's what happens.
Even if it's something silly.
Like if I see a movie that moves me,
I might go on stage and be like,
did y'all see this movie and where are
you working out now?
I know you do the store and I know you
do the factory,
but do you fuck around and go to the
[inaudible],
the ice house flippers,
all that shit.
My start was I,
when I,
when I knew I wanted to do this,
I was going to open mics and then I went
to Long Beach.
They had just placed cog queen,
the Queen Mary and they had a laugh is
hope.
This Guy Steve Kimbro had this really
shitty club on the Queen Mary.
We did fear factor and the Queen Mary.
It was right down there.
And I remember someone was doing a room
there.
That's the room you're talking about.
So I did that and then I started doing,
uh,
the ice house.
The annex does a good room and they had
that three shows on Friday,
three shows on Saturday.
So that started doing that.
From there I went to the Ha,
ha.
Then I was like hosting on the weekends.
And then Terry Terry from the hall,
you know,
God bless her soul.
What are you doing?
Wednesday night?
Wednesday night.
I'm around.
You want to do the Ice House?
Yeah,
let's do it.
I'm just saying that 10:00 PM,
10:00 PM,
Nice House.
I'm with Joe Rogan.
Tony Hinchcliffe on the show to the
other Tony.
So then I went to the.
I went to the ice house,
then I started going to [inaudible] and
then I got to showcase at the comedy
store and Mitzi didn't even look at me.
She didn't even look.
I didn't even talk to me.
What year this was.
It was a year.
Jay Davis got passed so I wanted to kill
myself.
I showcased with Jay Davis.
That's not rude.
Jay.
Jay knows I'll say this to his fucking
face.
He knows.
So we're showcasing the same day right
as she passed him and then didn't even
talk to me.
Okay.
So I wasn't even watching.
She didn't want.
She watched me and I went down.
I was,
like I said she didn't like it.
That's what I thought,
not which really pissed me off here.
His skin do.
This must have been 2000,
2003 ish.
So this is when Jay was on Torque.
Asm with Dane Cook.
Dane was supposed to showcase that night
too,
but he refused to come because he was
Dane Cook and I get it.
So he refused to show.
Well,
that's what I hear.
I shouldn't even say,
oh,
I should have asked him before I'm
talking about this,
but I had.
You had to showcase,
right.
I know Louis Ck didn't get passed at the
store.
I mean like she got her own thing,
so I,
I get to showcase my then friend a Metta
Med is setup to showcase that night and
I didn't get passed so a year and a half
later I had to,
I had to deal with Tommy,
you know,
and,
and listen as,
as what people get on him and I,
I think Tommy's out there thinks I hate
him,
but I know there was a method to his
madness,
you know,
and it.
And maybe if he didn't even know it,
it worked for me because he was my
villain.
He was my enemy.
Okay.
So I had to get past him.
He was the gatekeeper.
I had to get past.
So it took me a year and a half of doing
belly room and,
and,
and just hanging around and people keep
saying to him,
Hey,
you should put her griffin,
you know.
So then I got another showcase.
It was in the main room,
uh,
during one of those bringer shows.
They were doing the showcases during
those and she was there.
They had her in our booth and I did my
set.
I ran the fucking light to,
you know,
I was like,
fuck this,
what year are we talking about this?
This is like a,
like a year later.
So it's like 2005,
2000,
about 2005,
2006 around,
just around that time.
Two thousand four or five six.
I'm not sure what it was,
you know.
And then as I'm leaving there,
they're bringing her through the,
the,
the main room and their,
you know,
their hair helping her through the
hallway to go to the kitchen and she
stops and she looks at me and says,
you have funny.
Those are the only words she ever spoke
to me.
That's all you need.
That's all I needed.
And then Tommy comes over and he was
like,
wow,
yo,
Yo,
she passed you.
You're in the belly room now headbutted
him.
Retina knows was fucking mouth,
right.
Fuck.
And then he told me I had to be in the
belly room for a year.
And I knew that was a lie.
He passed me.
So again,
but I needed the,
I needed the challenge,
you know,
one of my best moments for me personally
because I got to tell you,
handbag
bad richard over at a comedy and magic,
you know.
And I love it.
I love Richard.
So I tried to,
I tried to showcase for Richard are the
nicest people ever.
They were so nice.
They treat comics that asked as you go
there,
you go there not to do comedy.
You go there to get food at a hug,
hug people hanging out with good people,
man for real.
So I remember I tried to showcase for
him,
I sent him a tape and he was like,
Erica,
too dirty and all this stuff and he
wouldn't pass me.
So Mazda Brawny.
This is years later now.
Mazda bronys doing a show and he says,
Eric,
you won't be on my show,
so I'm standing in the hallway before I
go on with the MC and then we're joking
about being clean,
and I said,
you know what,
I'm going to go up there and pull my
dick out.
A guy in a suit is walking down the
hallway.
This guy,
this dude just walking.
He goes,
hey,
please don't do that.
And I go,
you know,
I'm just kidding.
And we laugh a little bit.
We laugh a little bit.
I go onstage,
I'm murder it,
and then I'm headed to the green room
and that same guy in the suit comes
running at me and it's Mike is the
owner.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
And he says,
Hey.
He goes,
man,
you're hilarious.
Why aren't you working at my club?
Why don't I know you at that moment.
Richard is in the hallway and then I
look at Richard and I go,
yeah,
Richard,
why am I not working here?
He's like,
why would you do,
do you know you're dirty?
I was like,
I can play clean.
I play churches.
I played cruise ships.
I'm a professional comedian.
My point about this is that moment of
him squirming and like being like,
okay,
you're in Canada and after that I was in
that was worth waiting for as opposed to
like trying to bully my way into places.
Like I felt like I earned that.
Yeah.
And I.
and since then rich and I were friends,
you know,
it's like,
but I had to,
I had to earn that.
You have to earn it.
I had to like find the right moment.
I had to like,
you know what I mean?
I could,
I could.
I have been on the Wednesday night.
I saw show with Joe Rogan before
possibly.
Do you know,
like you got to get into these
situations.
Joey can't work with me at the Ice
House.
The one place they won't have them to
dirty.
What do you do with?
He went,
he went up and talking about sniffing
his balls and to many one to many cock
sucker.
Stick his nose up,
girls asses what's going down and I'm
from behind.
I do the pigeon and and they would just
fuck.
First of all,
he was murdering to the point where like
drinks were falling off tables,
the lights were dimming,
they're shorting out and Mike was like,
you know Mike,
the sweetest guy in the world.
He goes,
I love you.
I think you're amazing.
Like it was,
but I can have you in this club.
You're just dirty.
She's like,
look.
He goes,
I understand
Joe.
He wasn't mad at him,
you know,
he's like one of the only guys that told
Joey that he can't work,
but Joe,
he was already successful by then.
He just would work,
you know,
Joe,
he always works with me.
So he just didn't want to do it
is,
you know joey called.
You know what I got to say,
like one of the,
one of my favorite phone calls I've had
is Joey Diaz calling me the other day.
He,
you know,
I don't do this.
I'll call,
you know,
you will.
You're really good on.
I'm dying up here.
And he's just given me compliments.
That's beautiful.
And I just don't.
And I was like,
when this comes from someone that you
believe is 100 percent genuine,
and then the way,
the way he was talking about it,
I thought I was like,
oh,
that's great.
That's what you want.
That's what I learned when I got back
into it later too.
By the way,
when I was 30,
I knew that you had to get the respect
of your peers,
these people that you do this business
with have to think you're funny because
those are the people that are going to
get you work.
Well,
they have to,
like you said,
like youtube,
that's a big one.
Like Kevin would be a nice person and
you know,
we're going to be what you are in a very
nice person.
But one of the things that's nice about
the comedy store for sure is that,
um,
I think,
and this is,
I attribute this to the Internet because
I think what's going on with the
Internet now is there's so many
opportunities for the community,
for comedians now that we're not in
competition with each other anymore.
I don't think we've ever been.
We used to be like that man,
the nineties in the nineties,
everybody was like Doggie dog.
It was different like there was a lot of
people back then that felt like say if
you got something,
you got a TV show,
why didn't I get that fucking show?
As people that thought there was a
limited number of things.
It's what I call famine thinking.
You ever heard that expression?
Yes,
I know exactly what that expression is.
A deadly fucking.
It's just a poison to your life and the
way you think about the world that a lot
of people have that problem,
that famine thinking.
I think people still feel like that now.
And uh,
but I always,
I always liken it to golf.
You know,
I think that we're on a leader board,
but we're still fighting against
ourselves and no golf.
You're competing,
you're still competing for the
championship.
There's no competing at the comedy
store.
I know,
I know.
But what I'm the world of standup comedy
today.
I think there's so many opportunities.
There's so many places to work.
So many stand when,
especially when you're doing the road,
there's so many theaters,
so many comedy clubs,
so many,
but there's still only 52 weeks in a
year.
Think about that.
I'm gonna fuck.
Does that mean how many headliners are
there in uh,
in,
in do you think?
You know,
300.
Not Joking.
I've.
Okay,
well then that's your case maybe
worldwide.
Well,
there's only.
Okay,
well then that is enough because there's
like how many,
how many do you think there are?
How many?
Like is there a 500?
There might be 500.
Well,
let me say that a club though,
there's only 52 weeks for the macbook
from one guy up,
but that's one club.
So you travel,
right?
There's,
there's fucking hundreds of cities.
Well,
I mean it's still,
it's still,
it's still a fight out there,
man,
to fuck all that thing for the good
weekends.
What we get July fourth weekend.
Those when we get is I get,
I get mother's Day,
Father's Day,
July fourth.
Dude.
I get those too.
I do those weekends.
Yeah.
You can't come.
You're doing,
you're getting,
you're doing.
When's the last time you did a Thursday
night at a club?
I don't usually do Thursday night.
We go in the store.
What I'm saying you don't do it on
Thursday nights on the road.
Like road theatre is different,
but I'm saying like when you got,
there was a time when you got to a point
where you were doing Friday,
Saturday and you're out.
Yes.
At clubs,
clubs,
you know,
so there's still.
That was just because I just got tired
of the grind.
What,
what got me more than anything is doing
morning radio where you had to get up
early in the morning and then you try to
get some sleep and you never could and
then you just wrecked.
And then the only time he didn't get
right,
you're working.
It doesn't say that anymore,
but back in the day it did.
They still make you do it.
They're crazy.
That's a waste of time,
you know?
And it's always the same thing as a guy
on his psychic.
It must work in some places.
I don't know.
I mean I'm talking out of my ass.
If I applied,
I sometimes I'm going to go on when I go
on stage ago,
go who heard me on the radio?
Who's here already know?
Meanwhile you were up at 5:00 in the
morning.
I'm up in Boston.
Yeah,
that's the thing is like if you don't
get good sleep and that's a problem with
doing three weekend,
three nights in a row in different
places.
When I it,
I just in New York,
I was just night.
You got to the third night.
Well,
three nights in a row.
If you're just encountering lines,
that's okay because you're getting up in
the morning in the same hotel room,
but when you get up and you have to go
to the airport and then fly under the
new price,
take a shower,
go to the gym,
try to wake up.
That's where it fucks you up.
Three nights in a row,
by the time the third night comes
around,
you're like,
damn,
I'm kind of worn the fuck out.
Well,
you just said something that's not even
a part of my thing.
Like you know,
you,
you said like get up.
Go to the gym,
like I got an ad.
That ad that had that one man,
I fly somewhere.
If I fly in,
I put my bag down,
I unzip it,
I take my shorts out,
I put my fucking running shoes on or
whatever I'm going to where I go right
to the gym,
to the gym.
I don't fuck around because if I don't
I'm not going to do it.
I feel you.
If I'm.
If I'm standing in a nice hotel and you
have a 24 hour gym,
that's my favorite.
I'll just put my fucking headphones on
and just whatever they do in the gym,
get on a fucking elliptical machine and
do a half an hour.
Just make it.
Make it,
make yourself
sweat.
You know what I like to do,
and this is going to sound crazy,
but I love doing those like insanity.
Well that that's what I would fill that
spot with.
Check off.
I put my bag down,
take my shorts off,
get my one sock ready.
I never did that.
Does that
jerk off when you're shocked?
People were grossing.
This is supposed to simulate some sort
of like we'll see some sort of a,
some wooly pussy.
Pussy.
Let's see.
Was Silk Sock?
Yeah.
Even feels like you'll cut yourself.
But anyway,
like a flashlight with you on the road.
You're a creep?
Yeah,
mostly because the moment that they go
through your bag that they're at the
airport,
at the airport,
standing up.
Did that once right after nine slash 11.
He traveled with a briefcase.
No,
not a briefcase or a suitcase filled
with dildos and rubber fists and all
this shit.
Of course checked it everywhere anyway,
and that was why he was doing it.
They opened up his bag and like what is
this?
And they,
they can't say shit because sex toys
aren't outlawed.
Have you seen how crazy these sex robots
are looking?
Yes,
I have.
I mean I think we're,
you know,
how this feeling we have about
self driving cars.
There's a,
there's a fear out there about self
driving cars.
We're not there yet.
It's not going to be our generation to
fully embraces it.
Were 10,
15 years away from like,
this is going to be a normal thing.
Right.
Just the same thing with the sex dolls.
I think you're right.
When I see them,
I have a disconnect of like I can't.
I would never.
I just,
they just look.
You say that now,
but if it gets to like x Mokena style.
Oh,
well I mean jail.
That's come
to be self cleaning.
Lifesize sheep.
I googled sex robot sheep come pitch.
You got that bookmarked?
No.
Wait,
no.
wait,
wait.
First of all,
is this one on the left for pedophiles?
I don't know.
It's.
I just typed in sex robot girl mannequin
was realistic features.
What?
Whoa.
That is creepy as hell.
I don't know about that one right there.
Did Jesus Christ.
That is creepy.
That one of the left was the one.
The real doll.
Fucking little kid.
Guess what I'm saying?
Yeah.
That is creepy as shit.
Well,
I guess that's one way to.
You know Jamie,
don't click on that display.
It's not a sex robot.
I don't know why it's popping up there
yet.
The why'd you click right on the crap?
Hold on a second,
but that's under,
but you did a sex robot and that's
what's coming up in.
The first thing is shop for a sex robot
on girl mannequin with realistic
features.
That's fucking gross
meat.
Harmony.
The sex robots.
Go to her.
Go downstairs.
That looks like at least a grown ass
woman.
Sex robots go fullscreen.
Nope.
Let me see this shit.
This is the one I've seen.
There's always some.
Well,
it looks like my phone
telling my God that's what she looks
like.
She looks that good.
Yeah,
we're getting there.
Oh,
just something.
Oh Wow.
Jesus.
That's how they want it to.
With the head cover.
Just to ask some weird.
Oh God.
That's even weird to look at that hole.
Where the neck is.
Jesus.
This is.
Yeah,
so the dam.
That is unbelievably lifelike though.
It's crazy.
Like,
come on man.
This is a scene in a science fiction
movie because this was like 1960 and
this is a science fiction movie.
Oh,
she can blink slowly and seductive.
Look at it because she's blinking lips.
I know.
I don't know.
Like if this was a science fiction movie
from like the 19 sixties and they had
this,
we'd be like,
whoa,
this is crazy.
Because it would be so far removed from
farfetch.
There's no way that this is going to
have a look at what they're doing,
but this is not far fetched.
This is close.
You know what?
I think that this is going to be
bypassed by his virtual reality,
like brain links or some sort of thing
where like you,
you can stimulate the mind in a way that
you think things are happening.
I think that's going to bypass all of
this technology.
I think it's going to be both,
but I think.
I think you're right that that's coming
too,
I think,
but I think this is coming to.
I think this,
this,
the ability to have like a real
realistic robot that'll fuck you.
That's not hard because you just think
about all the moves that it has to do.
Not a lot of moves.
I think you know,
also there'll be quiet,
you know,
you.
I think also a good thing if it's
possible is have a move.
Have a robot like that to practice
martial arts on,
like have a robot that throws punches
and kicks.
See now you're thinking about improving
society,
not just for sex.
So you can have a robot teach you to
play piano.
Teach you how to do like I'm just
talking about a robot that you can fuck
up.
Like leg kick you up.
You though body kick in.
It's not going to hurt training thing.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah,
it's totally possible.
Yeah.
Have it.
Like I'm a robot in there cooking.
How it doesn't,
you know,
it doesn't move quickly,
but it moves slowly so you can just work
on drills and shit is already have one.
Oh No,
no,
don't.
No they don't.
Jamie,
this is just a fucking punching bag that
moves back and forth and stupid things
done.
Like that throws throws back at you.
I want to a person this is like,
but this is good for us.
Hyperextending elbows.
You're going to miss this thing and hurt
yourself.
I don't think that's a good idea.
Honestly.
I think you figured it out.
Your idea about having a of take instead
of having a sex robot,
that same technology used for fine arts
training.
Yeah,
because I have a dummy that I practice
Jiu Jitsu on,
but it's like this.
It's called a but dummy.
It just lays there like this and.
But I can practice armbars and
triangles.
I get reps on it.
I just don't call.
Right.
But it's not as good as doing it with a
person,
but it's hard to get a person to stand
there and let you do fucking choke them
over and over and over.
And I'm saying,
but a robot.
A robot could.
You could get us male sex doll.
You gotta order it specifically.
I want the sealed.
I want the Dick removed from mouth post.
I want to hold on.
Hold on,
hold on.
Why does the butthole need to be sealed?
So you don't want to be tempted?
Can accuse me of
it doesn't even work,
Bro.
Show you can take the gate off.
Joe.
Why does the butthole still work?
I specifically called and said,
no,
no.
Why is this cock so large?
Larger glistening.
Why does it smell like strawberry?
Yeah.
She'd always be dirty to here.
Why is your feed to couple of specks of
blood on it?
It shouldn't feel like it's been cleaned
and used.
You keep the plastic on it like a phone,
you know when you get your phone.
But those
real dolls,
they move like a real person like you.
If you didn't mind practicing on the
girl real doll,
you would order the girl real dog with
like small breasts,
you know,
so like the breast don't get in the way
and then you can work your mount,
get armbars in your triangles and then
when you're done you fucker.
Oh,
there you go.
There you go.
This was probably like dating,
you know?
No,
it's very different than dating.
Oh.
When you dated quite a few data,
UFC like do you think wanda rods,
the inner guide?
Do they have like they get excited like
that when they're like fighting each
other,
I doubt it.
Or they just stay away from that
completely.
I bet they do that,
but they don't even train together.
Well,
she's done fighting now.
She just does wwe,
which is great.
Yeah,
I think that's great for her.
Well,
she's great at it.
She's very good at it.
She's a decent,
decent enough actress.
She's an entertainer.
Yeah,
and that's.
This is supposed to be anyway,
so I'll entertainment right?
It's like,
what is it for?
It's just to distract you and give you
something fun to watch.
But we're so close to Roman times where
like,
you know,
we want someone.
I mean,
you see that bare knuckle boxing event
they did this past weekend.
No Sec could,
I can't with that man.
I'm just not.
I just not into like watching violence
like that.
I didn't have a problem with it,
you know,
because they don't know why.
It's like,
like Mohammed Ali,
like how he was in his later in his
life.
I go,
why would anyone do this?
Even when I watched professional
athletes like,
oh my God,
this is what I'm saying.
Like I can't.
Wow.
They did it in Wyoming.
Legalized bare knuckle boxing.
That just looks horrible.
Well,
the idea is you can't hit people as hard
with bare knuckles,
so you're going to get cut up a little
bit,
but you're not.
You're not going to the same kind of
head trauma.
No one willing to do to.
No Man.
What about,
what's his name to hit a rudy Tom.
John of.
I don't know who that is.
The coach coach from Houston.
Remember when he was playing in the NBA
that they used to fight in the NBA in
the seventies.
They fist to fist fight.
They used to have real fights at.
Somebody's got 77,
got clocked in the head and he,
he broke his orbital bone.
So this like,
this was normal oil things,
man.
Let me say that they would just.
Oh,
you know what I'm talking about.
He found it.
See now you got to see the replay.
Yeah.
Cause he came,
you know,
so what's what's happening here.
It's hard to see what's going on.
Rudy comes and this guy clocks him in
the head.
Oh,
I was looking at the wrong dudes.
Yeah.
Watch.
Here he comes.
He's just coming in to like to like stop
the fight and this guy thought he was
coming at him and he's running right
towards that.
Ruined his career.
Did it?
Yes.
Well that's an orbital fracture and
that's real common in mma.
It happens all the time,
but like imagine with knuckles.
No,
I do you really think that that's not as
bad.
I'm telling you with gloves just as bad.
I can hit harder.
Trust me.
He can hit someone hard too because it
doesn't hurt your hands.
There's the gloves are not protecting
the opponent.
The gloves are protecting your hand.
Well,
I get that from doing this box because I
take my hand out these gloves and my
fucking fingers are killing me.
Right.
Take,
take no,
no gloves and go over to my heavy bag
because that heavy bag is stiff.
Go over and start punching that.
I get it.
Same with punching a person.
14 ounce or 16 ounce?
I don't.
I'm not sure which one,
how to feel,
but sometimes I went to 14 ounces.
I feel like,
oh,
this is a little more speed.
I got a little more.
Yeah,
two extra ounces.
Yes and yeah.
Well these are zero ounces hands move
very well.
And MMA there.
Four there.
Four ounce.
Oh,
I couldn't even listen.
That looked terrible.
Those guys' faces.
That can't be.
You could break someone's nose.
Dude.
Everybody's nose gets broken in the UFC.
Everybody,
everybody's face gets broken.
Orbital bone.
This is your world,
man.
I get it.
I hear you.
I turned the thing on and I hear your
voice and the other day I was on Fx.
I was like,
oh that's Joe Rogan and you're just
going in and you sound like a totally
different person.
It's crazy.
You get low.
Like you're like,
like you're,
you're in a whole different.
Like in that mode too,
you know,
you just sound like if it was like
rocky,
rocky movie,
you know,
and then you hear the announcers,
that's you right there.
You got it down man.
Well,
but doing it a long time to get us all.
But that's your world.
So I'm not trying to disrespect your
world,
but it's just too violent for me.
What you've seen with that punch.
That was 1977 and they probably didn't
know how to fix those things back then,
but now they know how to fix orbital
fractures and things along those lines.
Does that make it okay?
But I'm telling you it's not that guy
punched that guy with gloves on have
been just as bad as it was.
Boxing gloves,
boxing gloves.
He probably wouldn't have got hurt as
much because you're dealing with a big
thick,
heavy pad,
you know,
box goes eight,
10 ounces depending on the fight,
you know,
I'm just.
Yeah,
I know what you're saying.
It seems like it does,
but I didn't know that is what you get
mostly as cuts.
Like you see those guys were all cut up
because the knuckles,
the bare knuckles are hitting this.
Heres what I do this and I'm knocking on
it.
I just feel wow.
I just feel how that would be like,
oh man.
Well it's because a lot of people.
I was saying for the longest time you
shouldn't have even wraps on your hands
because it gives people an unrealistic
idea of what you could do with your
hands and why are there pads on your
knuckles when there's not pads on your
shins?
Are Pads on your knees or pads on your
pads and your elbow because you're
smashing people with elbows.
This is way more power that you can
generate hitting someone with an elbow
with a bear elbow than you can with a
bare fist because a bare fist,
if you hit someone in the forehead or
even in the cheek,
sometimes you break your hand.
Yeah,
not with the elbow.
The elbow.
You could hit foreheads and face.
You can hit everything good head.
But to,
it was a jamie.
I'm gonna.
Have you pull something up because I
sent this to shop.
Um,
there's something that.
Give me one second here and I'll find
this because,
uh,
Josh Emett,
see if he could find just google this.
Josh Emett details.
Hellish road back to health following
Jeremy Stevens Kao.
And then they find the stuff you got
over there.
This is Alpha brain.
It's a cognitive form,
just the limitless pill.
Motherfucker.
Motherfucking.
It actually tastes good after this.
Now for you,
we're gonna be talking about science and
so this dude,
I can't even open it.
I don't want to bite it and tear it
open.
That dude got k owed by Jeremy Stevens
who's like one of the most ruthless
knockout artists in the UFC and he's got
major facial fractures,
Major.
He his like orbital was fractured.
His cheek bone was fractured.
His nasal cavity was fractured,
like fucking everything is fractured and
he just had emergency surgery.
The second surgery,
he went to Orlando where the fight was
and they either misdiagnosed him or they
missed some of the injuries,
but he was still fucked up.
They didn't catch a lot of things.
He says,
and then he went to another doctor and
got an MRI and they immediately took him
into surgery.
Like,
dude,
this fucking whole head is broken.
That's what I'm saying.
I don't get it.
This is legal.
Here's my.
Have you bought yourself?
You find this stuff?
Not.
There was no mma fight and I kickbox and
I fought in a lot of taekwondo
tournament.
You know,
there's no,
there's nothing in you to know right
now.
I'm 50 years old.
The fuck am I doing doing that?
They got like a 42 and overleaf
don't.
But there are some guys that are in
their forties.
They still fight,
but it's just,
it's a young man,
a young man's game,
right?
It's also a young man's game because by
the time you're 40,
you got to think you've been doing it
for a long time,
which means you've been absorbing a lot
of punishment for a long time,
which means you're probably,
you should probably be done if you want
to live into your seventies and eighties
and be able to hold your bowels in and
know where your keys are.
You know,
there's a certain point in time we can't
get hit anymore.
Do you look at even other sports you've
noticed?
Have you ever seen these old basketball
players?
How he can't walk?
Yeah.
It's crazy.
It needs to get devastated.
They're like,
doc rivers,
I got clippers tickets,
so I'd see doc rivers,
he's on the sideline and he can't even.
It was also really tall guy and that,
that alone,
all those leverage points and all the
impact,
the constant.
Especially.
I mean a lot of these guys,
they didn't understand overtraining.
They overtrain they had injuries.
They just toughed it out and work
through them.
Know,
back injuries,
weird spinal issues.
That's why I think they should let every
professional athlete for like there's a
week period where they get to take some
steroids and recover a week.
You're just not enough.
Oh,
okay.
Oh you know,
but you'd have to be on a cycle.
You'd have to be on a cycle for six to
eight weeks.
So in the off season you get that six to
eight weeks of like that cream,
steroid cream and cryotherapy,
you know,
they can do the Cryo to get your body
like I agree with the doctor gives you,
the doctor gives regular people steroids
to recover from certain injuries.
Sure.
And then when paying these people there
to entertain us,
whether we should allow them to take a
moment to like,
okay,
well here's my six week period,
I'm going to get my steroids in and get
myself back to normal.
Then we'll start training camp.
I agree.
The problem is when you go on a cycle,
let's say if you want on steroids cycle,
your endocrine system shuts down and so
then when you go off the steroids,
your body has a normalization period.
And a lot of times,
I don't know the hard numbers,
but I think what they try to say is it's
50 percent of the time that you were on
the steroids.
So say if you're on steroids for three
months,
you would need a one and a half month
recovery period before your hormones
normalized.
Oh,
and sometimes you need help getting your
hormones to a normalized.
There's a bunch of things called
clomiphene.
There's a bunch of pitches.
Is that although also illegal stuff?
Yes.
All those are illegal.
There you go.
Depending on what.
You know what the regulations are,
what,
what sport you're in,
but in mma you went to other sports.
Do you watch football,
basketball and all that?
Are you just strictly.
I don't even know the rules.
I don't know what's happening.
When I watch a football game,
he literally a cave man.
Whistles.
I'm not.
I just don't have any room.
I look.
I watch professional pool.
Okay.
You're one of those.
I got you.
I just love going to Canada.
You don't.
Every time I go to Canada and that
turned on their espn and Canada sneaker
and they got like,
they got the,
they got curling messed up where I go,
we would never show this bullshit.
Kappa.
Can I get a Kleenex?
Niggas alien.
We just ran out of.
Here you go.
Nasally.
Yeah.
So it's not that like I don't,
I'm a caveman.
It's just.
I like what?
Jesus.
Hey Sarah,
how are you doing that on mic?
We've got a big nose.
That microphone,
but yeah,
but you're blowing hard with that.
[inaudible].
You go deep son.
You just made people throw up those
people.
Listening to the funny of the fluid
coming out of people's noses is so vile
that sound,
you know,
like when someone like you on a
basketball court or something like that
and someone does a rocket.
Oh,
you see it like
this,
this from the guy that wants to watch
blood on people's face.
I don't want to watch blood on people's
face.
I just think that it would don't get it
stick.
You don't get a thrill out of when
somebody gets punched and then they turn
around and they're just like,
they're just like,
no,
I don't get a thrill out of that.
I get a thrill out of knockouts for
sure.
And which is worse guys hitting people
with big shots,
but it's like not specifically about
blood.
In fact,
I think I don't like blood because it
gets in the way and it stops.
Fight stops the fight.
Yeah.
That's the argument against elbows
actually said it.
Cut,
stopped good fights,
but they also knocked people.
Why don't you just throw that out?
Like garbage over there.
We had garbage and it's just fucking.
Just seeing it is like bothering you
right there.
Drop the double room.
Did sit on a table that's not trying to
get out.
It was like alien is.
I
had to get it out.
Sorry.
I don't know how we got from sex robots
was a circuitous path.
So what happens on this podcast?
Watched it a lot.
You don't go from like,
I'm like,
how'd they get there?
We don't even know.
We don't know what we.
Did you know how it got there?
Well I guess I should probably also
plugged my,
uh,
you know,
my new specials coming down.
Oh,
is that why you're here?
When is it coming out and the French at
home.
Get it.
June eighth on showtime.
American warrior.
I sent you a clip,
but I watched American warrior American.
Well with the American.
That is.
Eric is in the name of American.
Right.
And so I have,
I just spelled it with a k.
Oh,
American.
Oh.
I like,
oh,
look at that.
Americare on showtime.
Like it.
That's actually.
Ooh,
did that looks cool.
I like the background.
Where did you film that Shit?
In Portland,
at the Star Theater in Portland.
Oh Dude,
I love Portland.
Portland is great.
And this one,
my first special,
the ugly truth that I,
um,
I was talking about Kevin Christie.
True that for me.
Did he really,
isn't it fantastic.
Amazing.
Kevin.
So talented.
I wanted to be on a road and then like
have a chicken next to me with like
grenades on it,
you know what I mean?
Like we buy the chicken growth.
Yes.
That's a great picture though,
man.
That's just as he really.
He did a great job.
That looks amazing in this one.
I really go for it on this one man.
You know,
I'm talking about a ward show.
Protesting.
I'm talking about the kneeling for the
national anthem.
Me To tiger woods.
I'm going in on this in part.
So you're happy with it?
I am happy with it.
And think about like,
one thing that's weird about specials
now that,
that they have to be.
You could tell,
oh they filmed that a year ago or two
years ago and it's like we're not
allowed to like,
you know,
topical Shit,
do topical stuff.
And I feel like because there's so much
content out there right now,
it's like get it out there.
I want to know,
like for me,
like I want to know what Joe Rogan
thinks about,
you know,
the stuff that's going on,
I want to see you talk about it for 30
minutes on a,
on a national scale.
And we just don't do that.
And we got to do that now.
I think we should be doing that because
they're putting out stuff so fast
anyway.
Then it's like,
it's not like it's not special anymore.
If you need to stop calling them
specials special,
what is the name for them?
If they're not specials,
it should be like our conversations.
So this is Erik Griffin conversation
rolling stones don't put out a special
they put out,
they put out an album.
Like what did we did?
We put out a special.
They were special because it was only
five of them are year and you had to be
a giant to get one.
And it was like a.
and it was like,
um,
it was like a celebration of your career
and your fans.
It was like,
I've made it,
here's this,
so your fans could go yo to not fans.
Come watch this.
This guy is really funny.
And you now we're introducing four of
them in a career,
a career.
This is my second one now.
Nobody saw the first one.
You know what I mean?
So the first one,
wasn't that long ago,
10 years ago?
No,
it was last year.
It came out last year,
but I taped it two years ago,
year before.
So it took a year to come out.
It took a year to come out because they
wanted it to come out with the show.
I'm dying up here.
Sundays on showtime.
They wanted it to come out with the
show.
And so the same thing happened this
year.
Like I'm dying.
Appears out,
you know?
And if someone doesn't have showtime,
can they watch it on?
Can eventually they'll be able to.
But you know,
it's one of those shows.
Yeah,
you get to showtime anytime at showtime
anytime and yeah,
you could watch it there and I just
think that we need to.
I,
I want to hear with all this stuff
that's been going on,
especially with trump and the trump era,
I imagine like,
you see what he said today,
what he thinks he can pardon himself
too.
There's always.
He wrote pardon?
In all caps.
Hardened himself.
Pardon?
In all caps in all caps.
He wrote.
Pardon?
Like this is like,
like we did this.
Well,
people did it.
I did do it.
I voted for Gary Johnson.
He was on my podcast.
I voted for him.
What I'm saying,
you will say,
well that's a vote for trump.
Really in this day and age,
how dare you say not because it's
California and California went for
Clinton anyway,
but um,
because the coral Chia,
but by the way,
if they took,
if they got rid of the electoral college
and the Republican candidate would come
to California,
they'd go up to northern California and
they'd get 10,
15 million votes for them.
Anyway.
So northern,
northern California,
so anything between San Francisco and,
and you know all the way down the five
to come into here too,
not just northern California,
cause people think in northern
California as being like San Francisco.
But no,
no,
no.
Those hours driving above San Francisco,
drive for eight hours and still be in
California.
Yeah.
That's how it is a day drive.
If you go from Mexico all the way up to
Oregon,
it's a day it,
these people that live on the east coast
and Midwest,
they,
you know,
they turn in two hours,
they go through four states,
you know what I mean?
When they have it,
it's not us man over here.
And that's what's tough to.
Well that's why they want to change into
like three California.
So you heard that shit.
They don't want to do that shit.
They're talking about putting on the
ballot.
Poor state.
It wouldn't be good because la would
have all the fucking button.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean it would be la,
San Francisco and then farmers.
Yeah.
If you may just want to get with it will
be another.
What would they do that,
what would that do to the electoral
votes?
To the question like we have 55 now,
so then it would be like what?
Like the main epicenter where?
Well,
wherever there's urban ethnic people
though,
they're going to not.
They're going to draw those.
Jamie California is the fifth largest
economy in the world and the world.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Take that.
Or Gwyneth eat out the whole of the UK.
We beat out the United Kingdom.
United Kingdom is Scotland too,
right?
That's not just England.
Scotland.
Who else is it?
Is it Ireland?
Is that the UK?
Christ.
So the rents up big fucking place.
Isn't it like 20 percent of the entire
population of the United States live in
California?
Thirteen percent or something like that.
Something silly like one and we don't
know the real numbers.
I thought it was way more than that.
It's a little bit less than.
I thought it was more before.
I thought they think there's 20 million
people here.
I don't think they're fucking counting.
Did you ever get.
Does anybody count you?
Did you get counted?
The counters ain't counting anybody
that,
especially all the people that are here
illegally.
How many people do you know that are
here illegally?
I don't know too many people that are
here illegally.
I didn't know a lot of people that were
Canadian.
Bougie.
Now that I'm not even around people that
were were,
where would they be?
They don't.
We don't run the same circles.
Actually,
the lady that cleans my house,
she might be illegal
to
department to Department or do you know?
I don't have a house yet.
I'm saving.
I'm just.
I just.
I'm weird about it.
I'm just moved because I always feel
like this job I'm in now is the last job
I'll ever have and I'm going to need my
money.
Well,
let me stop you right there.
You're a funny dude and he's always
going to do well,
but I still don't want to.
I want to get the house.
I want that.
I'm going to get the house I want to die
in.
Do you have a podcast?
No,
I don't have time to get a pass to the
next thing.
I'm working on it.
To what you're good at this.
You'd be perfect at it.
I know I'm gonna,
you know,
we'll be.
We'll be competing.
Right.
See,
I have everybody on my podcast and
people that.
I mean supposedly competing,
but I want them to do well.
I think there's enough out there for
everybody.
I really do.
I think that this is about people's own
personal time anyway when they listen to
your podcast and then they listened to
the next one.
It's not like it's like it's not live
anymore.
Nothing's live anymore.
That's true.
I don't even know when my favorite
shows.
Come on.
I just put them in the queue and then I
watch him all my shows come on on Sunday
night.
That's how I look at it because that's
when I watch TV.
Yeah,
that's a.
that's a unique thing and most of the
shit I watched these days is on Netflix.
So it's all streaming.
Yeah.
What a juggernaut they are.
I don't think it's sustainable.
Can't be sustainable because so.
Well,
yeah,
but here's the thing.
If I drop $60,000,000 on,
I dropped $60 million to make a project
and you watch it in 10 hours,
then you're.
Then you're like,
hey,
um,
what's next?
The.
I bet you.
I guarantee you in a couple of years
Netflix is going to stop this.
The whole show comes out in one sitting.
They're gonna probably do it in chunks.
Why would they do that?
Because you want,
you anticipate anticipation.
What it does to your brain,
to the board room.
As soon as you walk out of this mine,
I'd be like,
fire them.
No ma'am.
He's retarded.
They're spending.
Have any idea what he's talking about.
Dope.
Anticipation.
Psychologically feels just as good as
actual achieving the thing.
That anticipation you feel like waiting
to see what happens next week you're on
a showtime show.
This motherfucker right here.
I'll see what's going on.
You're trying to like justify being on a
showtime show.
Good thing that they come out of.
It is a good thing.
It's a good thing you can bitch at the
end of the season for before engine
would.
You could still be shit,
but this model obviously is uber
successful like one of the most
successful things ever.
Then why are they talking about they're
losing money all the time.
What are you talking about?
The article about?
Look it up.
Netflix and losing money.
Netflix made hundreds of millions of
subscribers.
Know what they put out?
Pay $10 a month there.
They make more money than anybody,
but then also putting out money.
If they're given standup comics,
$20,000,000 to make special standup
comics.
What they put out 52 specials.
Even if they.
Let's say they paid 100,000,
which I know they didn't.
They paid way more than that for each of
them.
That's still a lot of money right there,
man.
I like how you didn't even bother.
I didn't want to $50 million.
I'm the worst at doing simple math in my
head.
I'm like 500 bucks to 25.
What is that fifth?
A lot of money.
It's a lot of money.
Dammit.
They May.
Stranger things.
Stranger things is an expensive show.
God damn good.
Show that people watch it in one week.
It's over there,
but then you're saying as a netflix
person,
hey,
what's next?
Yeah,
but millions people watch it.
Net Week.
No,
those people are justifying that $10 a
month that they spend.
That's when they have their contacts
constantly coming in.
It has to keep that really close to
suppress surpassing Disney's valuation.
Do you know how crazy that is?
Netflix.
Netflix special by the way,
in 2005.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
I didn't have the original was.
Oh gees on you.
You'd have $20,000,000 though.
Well,
I'm happy that that's showing you that
you're incorrect.
Now netflix is making shit tons of
money.
Know.
Just because they're valuable doesn't
mean that they're making a profit and
taking on debt.
So like they're playing a.
it's business.
So.
But how much are they making uber?
Uber's evaluation was,
I think they took on like another 8
million area.
Excuse me.
$8,000,000,000 in debt.
What does that mean though when I do
that,
but is it based on their earnings?
Like because they aren't they making
billions of dollars a year and they're
making money.
Then they took on more debt.
So they just have reinvested it back
into the company like they're not really
interested in turning a profit.
Maybe for 2017,
they're looking more into like 20,
25.
That's what I'm talking about man.
Do you know what you're saying?
Did you guess it's not sustainable?
Do it.
Hold on a second.
But how much do they make?
Let's find out instead of just guessing.
Not that I didn't give a fuck,
but obviously it does because he's so
invested in showtime.
Fuck this guy's model of.
What is showtime due to you at that
time?
I saw you a Netflix special that I did
in 2005.
We actually sold to showtime since I got
the rights to it.
And then are you going back to Netflix?
Give one of them licensing deals,
licensing deal.
Just going to.
I don't know what it's going to be.
I don't know.
My first special I did with rooftop,
which was now owned by Amazon,
so I think you can get.
The audio is good.
You can get the audio on.
I think Amazon's going to buy Netflix.
Watch what showtime has done for fucking
Sebastian.
I'm is not a bad place to
be if showtime wants to be in the air
griffin business.
I'm all about it.
Yeah,
no,
I hear you man.
You know showtimes great.
I'm actually wrong.
So my special comes out on Friday,
but only 10 minutes at a time.
So the next week
you'd be in the middle of a bit and
think about bill cosby.
Don't,
don't tune in next week.
Hey,
that might be the new model man.
American war episode too.
You've got to come up with dude,
you got to come up with some kind of
gimmicks.
It's like there's so many specials out
there.
Just keep swinging.
That's what I'm doing.
It's just me on stage.
There's no skits in the front or the
back end.
Good.
There's none of that shit.
It's just you just walk on snow.
Somebody introducing me who shit is just
walking on stage and that's how you
doing it.
So it just turns on.
Walk on stage.
Okay.
That's going to be the next one.
No introduction.
I did introduction last time,
like that's a waste of time because
especially when you have to cut it down.
I had to cut out nine minutes.
Oh,
it's tricky.
Right minutes.
People don't understand how long.
Nine minutes is on a.
on a.
for comedy.
Yeah.
That's a long ass time.
So I was shooting babies.
Manage you film.
I did twice.
Twice as good.
I,
if I had to do it again,
I would want to do a four times.
That's what I do.
And I would take the two second shows me
the one.
Hm.
You know.
Well I did four last time at San
Francisco.
My last one and this one in Boston.
I did for two.
What you got for money,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
You got to pay more for money,
but you know what?
For me it was like,
uh,
no,
you want to be loose.
And because of that I was looser in the
first show I've ever been because I knew
I didn't just think I had two barrels
mile.
I was tight as fuck.
And my first show here in crowd was
portland,
you know,
so it's like these liberal pretentious
white people talking about.
I'm talking about all kinds of.
It was,
man,
you have to own it when you talk about
this stuff,
you've got to own it.
You do have to own it.
Unapologetic.
Alright.
That's how you have to do it.
So the second show was so loosey Goosey
and you know,
I thought,
I think I captured something here.
Diaz Portland's an interesting place
because it's free liberal to the point
where they go so far left that they're
like militant in a way.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
But had a great time there,
man.
I was,
I had a great time there.
Last time I was there,
I was like six months ago.
I fucking loved it.
Do you find it like out there,
it's in this trump era.
I find a comedy has been challenging.
It's differently.
It's not just the trump era.
It's the era of outrage.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
But what I'm saying is I find that trump
people are angry winters,
you know,
they're angry winters.
Like you won your guys in office,
the globe glow and then like you say
anything and they're just like,
fuck.
If you say anything bad about trump,
it's crazy.
I have to fucking come.
They come hard and I don't get it.
I get it.
That's your guy.
Get it in the assholes.
Assholes have never been represented
before.
For Real.
I don't know.
I think there's no for real at a few
minutes.
Politician who's overly assholeishness.
Yeah,
he's definitely.
What happens when has that ever
happened?
Never,
and I'm a very stable genius causing
something stable.
Genius to that tweet is his dark where
he says,
I have every right to pardon and all
letters in all capital letters myself.
I looked at that this morning.
I got sick to my stomach,
a little guy that does it know how to do
the job and it's not his fault that he
was given the job like,
well,
he was.
He went after it.
I know,
but he said it's not his fault.
He was the best candidate in the
Republican Party,
like they should be the one that should
be ashamed of themselves.
I was watching the Trevor Noah's show
and he was showing this clip of trump at
a rally.
This is not.
He's already won and he's up there
saying,
you know,
I uh,
uh,
I,
they,
they told me to say drained the swamp,
right?
I didn't like it.
He's saying this,
I didn't like that,
but they said it would work.
It would stay like he's,
he,
he even has contempt for the people that
believed the bullshit that he was
saying.
He has contempt for them by just going
like,
you know,
I said these things just to get elected.
And it worked.
And like these other people,
they just were horrible candidates.
Kevin,
Christine.
And so he was Chris,
Chris,
Chris.
I said,
Kevin,
Krista.
He was on my mind,
the guy that drew might be awesome
artists,
the awesome artists.
So you know,
Kevin is right now listening to this
going,
what the fuck do I know?
Run for office shit.
I don't know.
I'm just fucking here.
So why wouldn't you be an asshole?
Why wouldn't he be like a sore winner?
You know what I mean?
I get it,
but it's the age of outrage and this is
what we're seeing from this Roseanne.
Stuff like,
dude,
I've been called a racist more times
over the last few days for defending
Rosanne,
saying that I know her,
she's mentally ill and then she's on all
kinds of pills.
I don't think she's a racist.
I,
and I'm going to say this too.
I think that this is a.
just because you can doesn't mean you
should situation.
Can I tweet something inappropriate?
Of course you can.
Should you,
when you have all of these things that
you're responsible for.
Sure.
You're the lead of a show,
your show,
a family show.
You're on a family network.
You have a lot of people's jobs that are
depending on you and I think there was
just an error in judgment.
Oh,
100 percent I do.
I think that she's a racist.
I think that.
I think that if she had just called the
woman just ugly and,
and,
and talked about her,
her job,
what would this have been?
The same thing,
but you,
you add,
you know,
it's like if you call somebody a bitch,
okay,
there's a pro.
You people can have a problem with that.
You call somebody a black bitch and all
of a sudden that changes it.
No.
Yeah.
If you call somebody a black monkey
bitch,
then you're like,
okay,
where's this coming from?
Well,
perfect example is Samantha bee calling
Ivanka trump affectless cunt,
and she said it on TV.
She sent me that was prepared.
Like someone wrote that out as a part of
her monologue.
She said it on television and then they
apologized.
She's like,
ah,
should just set it and tbs like we're
good,
but the advertisers are not good.
They're pulling out left and right,
but here's the thing with Rosanne,
she's not.
Well,
this is a fact.
Like I know I've talked to her.
She's told me.
I've talked to other people who know
her.
I talked to people who worked with her.
She's mentally ill,
but it talks openly about it.
She does well on a second.
She's on a host of medications.
She's on antidepressants.
She's on Ambien,
she's drinking,
she's smoking pot.
She's 66 years old.
She's not,
she's not well.
She smoked cigarettes.
She's out of it like she's got real
mental issues.
Now here's the thing.
If she had problems with her lungs and
she was smoking cigarettes and coughing
up blood,
what would and and doing stupid shit
like trying to run marathons.
When people go,
hey,
you know what the fuck is wrong with
you?
You know,
you think you could run a marathon,
what do you,
you will you fucking stupid?
No,
they wouldn't because they'd go,
oh,
she's got an illness.
This is why she can't run.
This is why she's coughing up blood.
She's got a mental illness.
She's mentally ill.
This is a fact.
That's why she's on so many different
medications,
but she has mental illness.
What if you were starting to get
mentally ill?
Are you saying that like saying like
sort of overtly racist things?
First of all,
she did.
You should
know that lady was black though.
Have you ever seen that woman?
She does not look black.
She thought that lady was Jewish when
she said planet of the Apes.
She said it because of her haircut
because she looks like that lady from
the planet of the apes.
She swear she swears and she swear to me
on the phone.
This is her exact word.
She goes,
I would never fucking say that you think
I'm so stupid that I would call black
lady planet of the Apes.
She goes,
I thought she was Jewish.
look at her.
She doesn't look black or that makes it
okay,
doesn't.
But she's,
she's Jewish too.
I mean,
that was the other thing.
Someone said,
well look,
she did.
She did.
She did this.
She dressed up like Hitler and had jus
cookies and she was bacon and back in
the day.
Yeah,
she's a shitster by the way.
She's also Jewish.
You know,
I think she gets a free pass on doing
that,
but I think that when you make a
mistake,
this is what's missing from our society
now.
She made a mistake.
You should be allowed to apologize for
that mistake.
Live with the shame and then you move
on.
But what we're trying to do now is
remove people from society altogether.
Like,
I don't want to like sit.
I'm not going to like,
there's,
we're not going to excuse her behavior.
We're not even going to say that there's
a,
you know,
a reason.
Whatever the reason is,
all the mental illness and all this kind
of stuff,
it's still a mistake.
What happened?
She's well enough to work on a
television show,
so I'm saying she made this mistake and
I'm not with.
I'm not with saying that she's a racist
either because when I.
even when I read that,
I thought as A.
I'm just saying as a comic we say things
that a regular person that is going to
translate the math into like,
well this is because you don't like
black people or women or you don't like
Jews you don't like,
and that's not how we operate.
Just trying to be fun.
We just trying to be funny and I think
that she comes from an error where this
is what you would say to be funny and
biting.
Yeah,
and I think that when she looked back on
it,
she went,
oh,
I didn't know this person was black.
Now the people out there listening,
you couldn't believe it or not,
but at the same time,
the Susan Rice comment from a long time
ago,
it was way worse because she.
Susan Rice is clearly black and she did
a comment a long time ago.
I think it was 2013,
but she said Susan Rice is a man with
giant swinging eight balls.
That's what she said.
Now that is way worse.
That's way worse and that is a woman who
is clearly black.
I mean,
you look at Susan Rice,
there's.
She's not racially ambiguous at all.
This other woman,
Valerie,
I don't know her name,
Gerrit,
she's.
She's got straight hair.
She's got light complexion.
She's a tone.
It's all about intent though,
what you're talking about,
right,
but it's what her intent was to be
funny.
She is obviously not,
but first of all she was drunk and on
Ambien.
Ambien is a cla.
Hamilton Morris sent me an email about
this.
He was explaining it to me and then I
talked to a sleep therapist about it.
There.
There's a,
a type of drug that ambient is,
that's called a hypnotic,
and this is one of the reasons why
Ambien has so many weird side effects
associated with it.
Um,
my friend Kevin James,
Kevin James got up in the middle of the
night.
I cooked a meal,
went to bed,
got up in the morning and uh,
he had like his wife.
I confronted him like,
did you do that because I didn't fucking
do that.
And she,
and she's like,
no,
the foods in the trash,
like,
you cooked it,
you ate it.
He's like,
I did not,
I did not eat that.
And she's like,
okay,
if you didn't do it,
who did?
And he had to like come to grips with
the fact that he was on Ambien.
He got up,
cooked a meal for himself,
had no recollection of it.
Went back to sleep.
My mom was on Ambien.
She got up in the middle of the night
and drew on the shag carpet.
She had a white shag carpet in a
bathroom with lipstick and with,
with nail Polish,
like a little kid.
She goes,
I don't remember doing it at all.
She is.
It's scary shit.
I know a bunch of people that have had
weird experiences on that stuff,
but if you stay in somebody's house and
you were on Ambien and you messed up
their shag carpet,
you'd apologize to apologize for it,
but this is what I'm saying.
When they may be say she's also.
She's also drunk on antidepressants,
which you're not supposed to be,
and then she smoking pot,
which I'm sure you're probably not
supposed to do either when you're on
those things,
and she's an older lady who just got off
of an exhausting schedule that almost
she in her words,
almost killed her.
She was.
She had bronchitis when she was filming.
I'm saying,
she's not doing well.
She made a fucked up mistake and she
apologized,
but everybody wants a berry.
Herman and I,
and I'm not with that.
I'll tell you with you.
It's like you can't that,
but that's the society that we live in
right now that's dislike.
Jumped outrage right now.
What will be,
not just outraged,
but we want to end your career.
Like why do we want to end someone's
career for fucking up?
Like it's one thing,
like here's the thing,
like if she was not mentally ill,
there was nothing wrong with her.
Like say if someone from.
Let's just pick a sitcom theory.
Let's say the guy for Stevie,
stevie still what's on tv right now
because Devi Devi that a different type
of TV.
A guess on CBS or just beginning?
It's a new one that's on TV.
What's a new one?
Like if either one of these guys will
have to do anymore.
They don't have any anymore.
It's Big Bang theory stolen.
Oh,
it is?
Okay.
Alright.
Big Bang theory.
If that is a pretty blonde girl in the
I don't know what if that girl gets on
TV and she's or she gets on twitter and
she says something totally racist.
Throw some n bombs,
you know,
like,
and there's nothing wrong with her.
She's like,
this is just how I feel.
And then they come after and they go,
well fuck this bitch.
She shouldn't be on television.
She's racist.
She doesn't represent how America views
people in 2018.
She's archaic.
Get her off the fucking air.
This is what this is.
You can't get away with this anymore.
This is the 19 twenties.
This is 2018.
That would be acceptable.
I understand that.
If you found a real hateful person,
she secretly has like a swastika tattoo
somewhere and she's.
She's an evil person.
This is not the case with Rosanne.
This is just not.
It's just not the case.
She's an older lady who's mentally
disturbed and on a fucking host of
competing medications for her
consciousness.
Well,
that should be the reason why she needs
help.
That yeah,
we've got to get her some help,
but he's a crazy thing is like she was
America's sweetheart just a couple of
weeks ago.
Now.
I know now fucking.
That's how quickly everybody hates is
how quickly and people are calling me a
racist for saying what I said right
there.
This is not.
This is not an unusual thing in our
society like we this code.
This is very much reminds me of the
Salem witch hunt,
you know,
this is the same kind of thing a little
bit.
Right?
You know,
it's like the scarlet letter,
like how,
how old does the scarlet letter and
we're still doing that now.
Theism.
Yeah,
right.
This is something that we're.
We're,
we're prone to it.
Do you think it's because people are
scared that they're going to get called
out on it themselves,
so when they see someone who's doing
something wrong to go after him,
attack them with everything,
they have to almost to divert any sort
of.
Because people are scared that people
are going to turn on them.
Especially in this day and age when
people turn on people for like,
you know the garrison keillor story,
he's the saddest story in this.
Me Too.
Stuff because garrison keillor is a guy
who had the lake.
Woebegone chronicles is this pbs show
radio shows ongoing for decades and he's
a writer and he hugged a woman.
She was.
He was consoling her and hugged her,
and apparently while he was hugging her,
his arm went down her back on her back
and he apologized.
She pulled away.
He apologized.
He sent her a letter.
He said,
I'm sorry I didn't mean to do that.
She says,
don't worry.
No worries.
Don't worry about it.
Years later when all this meat to
frenzy,
she brings this up.
He gets fired.
They pull his name off the shelf for
touching a girl's back.
It's like the frenzy was so hot.
They didn't want to be accused of not
doing anything,
so they pulled this guy I know and you
know there is the worst side of it,
right?
There's the Harvey Weinsteins of the
world.
There's the people that are absolutely
monsters,
right?
There's those people,
but then there's people that just got
caught up in the wave of outrage and
it's just.
It's a strange,
a strange time,
like the.
There's no balance to it.
Well,
the pendulum is gonna swing until you
know our attitudes balance out.
I mean this,
the fact that the me too movement is not
a bad thing because it's bringing up
some serious issues that we've had.
It's a great thing to happen,
so in the meantime there's going to be
collateral damage for that until we now
get back to a time where we can like men
whack like gentlemen and we'll be able
to have interpersonal relationships with
women at work and in a setting and make
it professional,
but at the same time we also don't want
a sterile environment.
You know,
when you,
when you go to these seminars,
because like even for our show now,
because of all this,
you have to have like a sexual
harassment meeting before you start.
Well,
they had those in the 90.
Exactly.
I went to those for hardball show that
it was on in 94,
but one of the things they always say
because you can't define this right,
you know it when you see it.
Well,
that's what they used to say about
pornography,
but that's what we've lost.
That ability to understand that like I
think that that applies to me,
that's not a good definition.
It's probably but it,
but that is the definition.
It's the same thing that goes with
oversensitivity.
I think that too.
We should know it when we see it and
we're.
We're not.
We're not recognizing that.
It's like,
you know,
you're acting and this is a bit much
right now sometimes.
Did you hear about the two college kids
that got drunk and had sex and the boy
upon waking up and sobering up,
decided to preemptively accused the girl
of sexual assault because he was
intoxicated.
So he filed and went after her.
She got suspended from school.
They had to do it because otherwise they
would be sexist because they do it all
the time.
If it's a boy and a girl,
it's always thought that if a boy,
do you know the Occidental College
story?
So pretty famous story from a few years
back with these two kids that were in
college.
The guy called texts,
the girl,
you know I'm cone over.
She's like,
you have condoms?
He says,
yes,
you know,
so clearly intent has been established,
right?
Goes overhead sex with her.
Her friends convinced her because she
was intoxicated,
that it was sex under the influence,
so it was rape and so she goes to the
university officials and they suspend
the boy.
He sues and wins and the whole things.
The whole thing's chaos because this kid
gets kicked out of fucking school.
Actually did he,
when I need to know that if you want to
check fact check that Occidental,
but now you've got to happen now to even
interact with them when you have to have
a notary.
Well,
that's what they're saying.
People video.
I consent to,
you know,
so here's where it gets even screw here.
There was a real article the other day
that was saying,
is it physically possible for two people
to simultaneously sexual assault each
other and they're debating this in the
college because they trying to figure
out if two people are both drunk and
like they get together and they're both
sloppy and fucking hammered and they
decided to have sex.
Did they both sexually assault each
other?
Isn't this really about choices that we
make?
Well,
it's also about taking responsibility
for your actions.
If you're an adult.
If you decide to get in your car and
you're drunk and you plow into a bus and
kill a bunch of people,
no one says,
oh,
Eric was just drunk.
He is not responsible for his actions.
You're responsible for your actions.
If you're drunk,
if you're driving a car and he killed
somebody.
But the idea is that if a girl comes
over your house and you're drunk and you
know you're not responsible for your
actions,
and especially if you're a girl and
you're drunk,
you're not responsible for your actions.
Then if you're having sex with a guy,
but you're definitely responsible for
your actions.
If you're a girl and you get in a car
and drive and hit someone,
but at the same time though,
like a girl,
a girl,
anyone should be allowed to be with her
friends or with his friends and you get
sloppy drunk.
Uh,
you protect it.
You should be carrying.
You shouldn't be.
It's not okay that somebody decided to
like,
go further with it.
You know?
Well,
the most egregious cases obviously cosby
because that was his thing.
I mean,
if he did do what everybody's accusing
him of doing and we have no reason to
think he didn't,
he was taking people that thought of him
as a mentor and thought that he was
going to help their career and that's,
that was his hustle and he would just
drug them and they'd wake up with their
pussy sore and their fucking pants off
and not knowing what happened and be
super confused.
It's horrible.
I mean,
that's,
that's the worst,
the worst version of it.
But then it's like,
you know,
this is one of those things where I'm
saying it's like this.
That is hard to define.
There's no real definition.
You can't put it down in writing to say
like,
this is what this is.
Because then you got a situation where
you're out on a date with someone.
Things are going well.
You think it's going well,
you get into bed and then that person in
what for whatever reason decides,
uh,
I think we should stop.
I don't want to do this anymore.
And that,
that,
that could be,
that could be on the same level as drug.
And somebody,
sorry,
clubbing them on the head.
That girl writes that crazy fucking
story to 5,000 word story that is easy
as everything is just about him not
being a gentlemen.
Right.
That's all.
That was.
Not just dad,
but she was just grossed out by it and
decided to go after him.
But you know,
I know I can understand being in a
situation like,
you know,
people got on the woman because they
were like,
you know what,
Hey,
you still blew him three times.
Right.
But I understand that being in a
situation where you're like,
you're.
Because it's happened to me.
All right.
I,
I was at a comedy club,
you know,
I told this girl,
this was years ago.
I told her,
I said,
she was like,
I'm coming back to your hotel.
Like,
you know,
no,
I don't think you should.
I didn't want to.
I wasn't like I wasn't.
She forced herself on you.
It wasn't going to explain.
Imagine if you were a girl.
That's,
that's where it gets really scary.
But first of all,
everything she's saying to me this whole
night up to getting to my hotel.
If I would have done that to a woman is
assault abuse,
like threatening from the jump.
So we already talked about this,
but this is what happened.
So I get,
I say to her,
I was like,
I don't think I said it was really
interesting at the time I wasn't.
I was like,
I don't know if this is a good idea.
I think you should go home,
you know,
and then she's like,
no,
I'll walk you to your hotel because we
were hanging out the whole day.
Everybody's hanging out this place.
After the Sunday night show,
I said,
okay,
we get to the hotel.
I go,
well,
thanks for walking me,
but I think you should probably know,
you know,
I cleaned your dick with him now that's,
it's like a,
I will give you a massage.
It was all just kind of stuff.
I think you should go.
I'm not really.
Then my ego kicks in because I'm like,
well,
you know,
alright you,
you like me like this.
Okay.
So we get up,
we finally get upstairs.
I still am like,
maybe we,
maybe we shouldn't do this,
you know?
And then she starts to like,
Oh,
you're,
oh,
you're just because you're not into me.
It's because I'm,
I'm hideous or whatever.
So now I felt like,
oh,
I have to fuck her.
Fuck.
I felt like I got to do this.
It's like I had to do this because I
don't want to become a cause.
Like I'm,
you know,
what I'm saying about the reason how I
apply this to the zs situation is the
fact that this girl is in a situation
where she feels like,
I guess I have to do this.
Like I may not want to do it.
No,
we're speculating.
We're in a situation where I didn't
necessarily want to do it,
but I felt like the social pressure of
like,
well maybe I have to follow through with
what I'm doing right now.
No,
I get it.
Yeah,
that's definitely in the morning.
I had my hat to fly when we're not.
Even in the morning I say we're
finished.
And I'm like,
I said,
hey,
you know,
you've got to go.
Because I got a pack and she started to
cry
and I thought this,
if this was happening now,
this could be a situation.
It could easily be somebody.
She could tell her story differently,
so we don't know.
That's why there's no rules.
What this lady did was she was
aggressive and flirting and she wanted
what she wanted and she got it,
you know,
so that's sometimes is okay,
depending on the person that you're
dealing with.
But that same situation with someone
else could be.
No,
this was horrible.
I,
I felt,
I felt intimidated.
you know,
it's all in how you interpreted it will
interpret it.
Yeah.
It's definitely,
it depends on who's talking and whether
or not you're attract each other.
Here's a perfect example.
If you and your girlfriend decided to
get drunk and your girlfriend was drunk
and she called you up and said,
come on over,
you know,
uh,
I'm horny.
I want you to fuck me.
If you went over and did it,
you would,
in some people's eyes be guilty of
sexual assault because she was drunk and
she couldn't consent.
And this is why I'd never done that,
by the way,
my,
one of my ex girlfriends was like that.
She wanted to get drunk.
Really?
She was,
I just want to affect when I'm drunk and
I just couldn't do it.
I didn't feel were nervous about it.
It wasn't.
But it was just me personally,
I don't drink,
you don't drink.
I don't drink at all.
So I always felt like if I'm not
drinking,
it just feels like,
what if she says she wants to do
something that like she doesn't normally
want to do and then she's going to get
sober and be like,
why did you do that to my butthole or
whatever.
You know what I mean?
Like why?
And they like what?
But you said she gets.
Because it'll always come back to,
well you know,
I was drunk but I didn't really meet.
I didn't,
you know.
Then I'm like,
okay,
I don't want to be the choice maker.
And that was the best thing about not
drinking.
Right.
In that situation,
if you don't drink,
you never have to think like that.
But that's why sometimes I don't want to
hang out.
That's thought.
Sometimes I don't want to hang out with
people that are like,
they get dumb drunk,
you're out.
And then I become responsible.
Oh well what's the worst when you're
sober?
Like,
Whoa,
I don't want to deal with their
behaviors.
So fucking gross gross,
you know?
Then you see your friend,
especially if you have like a female
friend,
you're not,
you're not like that with them.
But then you're out and then she's,
you know,
her skirt is coming up and you see the
creepy guy.
You see the guy that she's just like,
Oh man,
what do I do right now?
But can I go if I don't stop her from
going?
And then something happens that she
doesn't want to happen is if a stopper.
And she's like,
yeah,
I fucking hate her
and we are going to have an amazing time
and you fucking hater this,
all this Harvey Weinstein and all this
kind of shit.
It's set.
You know,
it said ugly dudes back like 20 years.
All my advances that I've made with hot
chicks has just been like,
I'm so glad to have power.
Here's the thing,
it's not about ugly.
It's about Harvey Weinstein being in
control of a studio.
Zack and scaring all those girls into
fucking man,
allegedly raping some of them,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know what he did or didn't do,
but he definitely did a lot of shit.
I wish I just wished it.
A lot of these people will.
I wished it's too.
Maybe now people will have the courage
to come out because it's certain sex to
hear about like,
you know,
this happened to Angelina Jolie and then
like,
oh,
so then she.
There was a certain time when she was
like the most famous woman in Hollywood
and she didn't say,
still didn't say anything.
Yeah.
So we lived in a black ball.
I know it sucks that we live in a
culture like so maybe that's why some
innocent people are getting,
getting caught in the crossfire.
So we can obliterate this sort of
behavior and attitude from our culture.
But in the meantime,
while we're going through this,
there's going to be some dealers and
it's going to be some people that are
going to get caught in the crossfire.
Did you ever drink?
No.
Never.
No,
no.
I never.
I never wanted to.
Um,
when I was in high school,
we're going to have,
you know,
friends would drink and stuff and I just
wasn't.
I didn't like the taste.
I would tell you I haven't had half a
beer at a party one time when I was
like,
what?
This is disgusting,
you know?
And then it was,
you know,
what really decided to,
for me it was like the 1999,
2000 new year's,
like going into,
you know,
y two k going into that,
I was at a party that I was like,
I never want to be like this.
People were hammered.
Just that was a weird one.
Right?
Everybody was super drunk on y twoK ,
they thought it was
going to shut off wherever I was taking
care of somebody's baby,
you know?
Yeah.
Because that's what they're at.
This party.
I had a baby.
Who the fuck if you a baby?
No,
I was taking because they were drunk.
I was drunk and left you with their
baby.
I had the baby.
Mr. Yeah,
it was crazy part.
Fuck.
Are these people with a baby?
And I in that and the husband,
he poor kid is 18 years old,
man.
Fuck that.
Griff was babysitting.
Babysitting.
Taking care of people.
So then you hear these rumors,
you hear these stories about people die
because they're choking on their own
vomit.
So like there's people that are like
passed out like this.
So I got to turn people to their site
and I said I never want to be like this.
You were turning people into holding a
baby and holding a baby.
And Mr Wirtz Shithole party man.
And I got invited.
I got invited.
I went to some of my friends.
I was a,
I was the wolf and this shit dude.
I was the wolf.
So if you're having a party and you
think it's gonna get crazy.
You Call Eric Griffin and I'm going to
come.
Got The wolf.
Craziest party I've ever heard of.
So after that I knew I didn't want to,
so I recently I went with a buddy of
mine to,
on vacation,
you know,
and when we went,
uh,
that deal was,
he was like,
come on man,
you gotta have some drinks.
So I,
I had a head,
like a banana Daiquiri on,
on,
uh,
on a,
you know,
and I was like,
this is okay.
And then I had,
you know,
when you go to,
like,
you're going to a resort vacation,
that will always be like a special at
the bar,
you know,
like,
Hey,
help today's drink.
I said I'll try it.
I had like 15 percent of that thing and
I was loopy.
Yeah.
I was ready to,
you know,
tweet racist shit.
So I was like,
I was like,
Nah,
what about,
we'd know we'd either never,
never,
never.
My current girlfriend,
she loves we.
So I tried one time,
did you get nervous?
I was like,
I don't like this.
I said,
how do you,
I can't be like,
you know,
so that's why if I didn't have joe,
if I did ever have comedy,
what would you do?
I'd be a crazy person.
Well,
you're a crazy person now.
He just calming it down with comedy.
I,
you're a good,
crazy person.
You're a very nice guy.
Legit need comment.
I,
this sounds like one of those cliche
type of things,
but I,
I rely on it.
I go to therapy,
you know,
I go to there and just been great for
me.
You know,
it's really been great.
I love going to therapy.
I love because I feel like I can talk to
somebody and then intellectualize things
on a level that like you can't
necessarily do with regular people and
understands human nature.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
And they can go over,
Oh yes,
why you did this or what,
what was the insecurity that triggered
that apply?
And I've learned things about myself.
I'm learning things about like,
like I was the only child,
you know,
single mom.
So there's all these things I've
learning about like why I interact with
my girlfriend the way I do because of my
mom and like my friendships and why get
angry about certain things.
It applies to things on stage.
Yeah.
So I'm really why I have so many of
these types of relationships in my life
where people are like,
you know,
needy,
like I find myself being like the one
that's trying to help.
I don't have a lot of equal
relationship.
So I learned all these things,
probably felt vulnerable as a kid and
when you see vulnerable people you want
to help them can relate.
And my mom too,
my mom went through a lot to get to the
states,
you know,
she was from Belize in Central America
and like just coming here and hearing
her stories and like,
you know,
having,
having to like be somebody to take.
I had,
I was 15 years old how we to take care
of my mom,
like,
you know,
her emotions were.
And so then I,
that had an effect on me,
you know,
but I didn't learn this until I was able
to go talk to a professional.
Are you close with your dad?
I had never met my dad,
you know,
single parent.
You never met my dad.
So thanks for bringing that up.
I don't know.
Money that mine's name is Joe Rogan
Shit.
He's out there someplace.
He's out there.
Yeah.
I've never met my dad and then I thought
people.
Did you ever want to meet your dad?
Did you ever see?
You know what's funny?
My mom want me to met him.
I knew him until I was like,
oh,
that's worse.
I never knew.
So I think that that's when you.
If you know them a little bit and then
they're gone,
that sucks.
The good thing is that it made me
realize that you can't count on people,
but you can catch issues.
Definitely a trusted player become
someone that people count on,
count on people.
That's what you do.
Have a tight group of friends like me
and my friends are very close.
I get it.
I would do anything for my friends and
family to see.
I have a certain.
There's a certain level of loyalty that
I have because of that too.
Yeah,
well you understand it.
Whereas someone who grows up in a big
household filled with people and the
family was always there and everyone was
there.
You might take people for granted a
little bit,
you know,
whereas for me camaraderie and closeness
and all that,
that shit means a lot to it.
It's very,
very important.
I remember asking my mom about my dad
when I was like,
I don't know,
17,
18,
you know,
and she got really offended.
She was like,
I raised you and you know,
and that made me think like I was like,
but women have their secrets,
like they have their things and I didn't
want her to.
I never,
I don't regret your cry.
I don't want to pry.
And I didn't want to find out like maybe
he wanted to be in my life,
but my mom was like,
no,
who knows,
you know,
she think of my mom.
She could've been vindictive like that,
but I don't know,
but I didn't hold it against her.
But she told me his name and she was
like,
if you want to,
you just on your own,
you know,
that kind of thing.
And I had the name for like a week and
then I forgot it and that told me that
it didn't matter.
So I had ever since I never worried
about it.
Good for you.
Yeah.
It's,
there's some people that really bothers
them for their whole life.
And like one thing that happened though,
when you have kids,
your bond with your kids,
it's like it's.
I mean,
I,
I would assume that everyone's bond with
their children is very tight because
it's an unbelievable love connection
that you have with children.
It's true.
Unconditional love is not just true
unconditional.
It's like they,
they're a drug like they give you,
they give you love to the point where
like my daughter,
my,
my youngest was,
we were playing the other day in the
pool and there's a point in time we were
just laughing about something together,
just laughing and I'm looking at her
face and she's laughing and I felt like
I was on drugs.
I was like,
the love that I have for these people is
so,
it's so intense.
It's,
it's,
it's.
And it's also.
I didn't get that when I was kid.
I didn't know exactly what you're
saying,
man.
The parents,
my,
you know,
my mom worked,
my Stepdad was a really good guy.
But no one's ever around,
you know,
there's just,
there was no when they were done
working,
everybody was tired.
You know,
I was a latchkey kid.
You know what?
When I was seven years old,
I live in San Francisco,
would go out and do a magic show on
fisherman's wharf by myself.
Just wander around the city just so they
would open the door.
You just leave seven.
I can imagine that.
I spent a lot of time by myself too
because my mom was working by herself
trying to make it,
trying to make sure that I had a good
life.
So I was by myself.
You know,
Eric,
if you have kids with this young lady or
another young lady,
your connection with that kid will be.
It'll blow your fucking mind.
Change who you are.
I feel like that's what I've been
lacking.
That's why I've been more open to,
you know,
thinking about these kinds of things.
You seem like a dad.
Yeah.
Well,
because I'm taking a picture and your
dad right now,
my whole life I've been like,
you know,
I've been in that role for so many
people in my life right now.
We're holding a baby and turn it over
drunk.
Take you.
Yeah man.
I've been taking care of people like
pancakes,
care people my whole life,
man.
It's crazy.
So that's why I always feel like I
always feel like you have already had
one of my best friends in the world is
something that I've,
I've had to take care of,
you know,
he's had a little drinking problem and
yeah,
but I've been there the whole time and
I,
and even though people would be like,
you know,
you,
you have to like,
you know,
the people that think that,
you have to hit rock bottom yet.
But I'm just not like that.
I've been through that too.
I had a very good friend of mine is my
best friend who died of heroin and he
was um,
uh,
always fucked up.
There was always something.
It was always.
He had a crack problem for.
And then he got on pills and it was,
he was either snorting it or was,
it was like he already lying very much.
Reminds me of this guy.
And Joey Diaz did a little bit too.
When I first met Joey,
it was like right after my friend johnny
well was right before Johnny had died.
Johnny was still alive,
but I had known people like joey because
of my friend Johnny.
But um,
you know,
it's just,
I always was there for him.
I was always trying to take care of him.
I was always trying to help him,
but it was just,
he was always,
there was always something going wrong
and it never is.
But there was these brief moments,
man,
where he'd be fine and we'd be laughing
and we'd have the best time and that's
why you fight for it.
It's those times because I was always,
I was always thinking that one day he
was going to get it,
gather I the same thing with my friend
is still going on with me right now.
It's like,
you know,
when you have,
when you deal with someone that deals
with depression,
real depression,
you know,
lost his mother and how that affected
his whole life and it's like,
so I'm there and he's younger than me,
so I feel this mentorship and I just
feel like a loyalty that I just can't
shake.
So I,
you know,
so that's that.
And I know what I said,
when I go to therapy I,
I,
I want to ask why am I this way?
And then I realized that comedy has been
dampering my own depressions or my own
feelings because I feel like I'm dealing
with it in some way.
So sometimes I go and talk about things
and I talk about things in a way I just
no holds bar because I want wanna,
I want to get this out,
I feel like this,
you know,
or if I don't like something.
And then combined that with we live in a
society right now where people don't
want to necessarily hear an opinion that
is not,
there's,
well,
there's definitely a little of that
right?
And so then therefore we get this.
Like,
it becomes tougher and tougher to do
what we do,
but it's not gonna stop me from doing
it,
but that's,
it's sweeter and sweeter when you pull
it off,
you know,
especially controversial shit.
Just got to navigate the waters.
What I feel like I've been,
I've been doing it.
I think I did it with this special.
I think I tried to talk about things in
a way where I was like,
okay,
you may not agree,
but you don't have to vilify me,
you know,
you don't have to like,
you know.
But,
um,
anyway,
it all goes back to like,
you know,
uh,
like who we are as people because of
like our,
our parents,
you know,
and it's like I,
my,
I love my mom.
I love my Stepdad.
Stepdad is a great guy.
I'm glad he's in my mom's life.
You know,
they're off in Spain right now.
They moved to Spain,
like,
uh,
like I say like a year and a half ago.
And so they're there,
you know,
and uh,
I'm,
I'm happy that she's happy in the later
part of her life.
That's awesome.
You know?
Yeah,
that's mean.
Look man,
at the end of the day it should be just
about enjoying this experience.
Just having time with people you care
about and enjoying it and it's hard to
figure it out.
What do.
I mean?
We're very,
very fortunate in a lot of ways,
but one of the big ones is that you and
I found comedy and you imagine.
I mean,
don't you tell the people sometimes they
go,
how the fuck they live without telling
me
how do they live without killing?
When I see some bullshit happened tv I
go,
that guy
needs to go do an open mic set.
You need to go get that out man.
Go get that out.
Well,
you know that feeling that you get like
Friday night and the,
Oh,
are you just mash and you get off stage?
You're like telling me there's a better
feeling of it because whatever I was
feeling,
it all goes away.
Yeah,
but that's why I feel like.
I do think though,
there's,
sometimes we're like putting a damper on
it and it doesn't necessarily go away,
but we found another outlet to get it
out.
Well,
you just got a little toxic hating man.
You take it a little happy pill,
but you know,
like there's happiness and all sorts of
things that you enjoy doing.
I found I've tried to fill my life up
with activities that I enjoy doing,
but family is a big one too.
Man.
Family is,
um,
it's a,
it's a different thing,
man.
It changes you.
You and I'm all.
I have all daughters.
It's all my house is off.
It's so feminine.
Everything's females.
So,
I mean,
I've talked about it on my special,
about,
you know,
the Bruce Jenner thing about,
that uh,
my last special,
the one before this one,
that it's just that if you live with
crazy bitches long enough eventually
become.
I am becoming more and more familiar
with a more feminine version of
yourself.
Oh my God.
I'm so much more feminine than I've ever
been,
ever so much more in tune with how girls
think so much more tolerant of like
nonsense talk because like when you're
talking nonsense talk,
it's just different,
but it's just like you realize like if,
if I'm around like women when they're
talking together and I'm going to
observe her and I wash them,
they just talk about different shit man.
I mean there.
And then when we've just talked about
different shift for two hours,
if you like,
try to interject,
interject and go,
Hey,
do you guys see that bare knuckle boxing
fight was fucking awesome.
Like let's get away from the.
Yeah.
Like for them,
what you're interested in is stupid and
for them,
you know,
they,
they want to talk about whatever the
fuck they want to talk about that
they're into at the moment.
Whether it's shoes of the royal wedding
or what relationships have had been in a
relationship for this long now has
taught me patience,
patience.
It's taught me patience.
It taught me like that too.
Except the double standard that things
aren't supposed to necessarily be equal
that they're supposed to be.
I always think that it's one of those
scales,
you know,
and you put stuff in the scale on this
side and she puts different things,
but that's how you balance out.
But they don't have to be the same
thing.
You know,
people don't give love in the same way,
so you shouldn't accept.
You shouldn't expect it to be the way
you give it,
but that becomes a problem.
You know,
that becomes a problem.
I had a girlfriend once that she,
she didn't express love in a way that
was like hugging and she didn't want to
do it that way.
She wasn't affectionate,
she wasn't affectionate.
She like,
she buy me a TV or something,
you know,
but it's so weird and I understood
though because it was because her family
wasn't like that.
They weren't.
It wasn't.
They weren't a huggy people,
but I was,
don't feel sad for people like that.
That I do.
I do is we need human interaction
interaction.
We need to connection.
We need to,
we need to feel,
you know,
we need to feel that.
And then we also need smiles.
We need smiles from people.
I was telling my girlfriend,
like,
you know that you're the most beautiful
when you're just,
like,
happy and smiling because the moment she
isn't,
it's like,
what did I do
that shit.
I know what you did.
I wonder if she's mad and she.
Is She mad about this?
I know she's mad.
What did I do or,
or what does she think I did preemptive?
Like if I do that,
will she get mad?
Oh my God,
do I know
it's like a divinci code,
man.
We're just trying to figure out.
And that's what I'm learning with her.
But I remember I was,
I was with a girl that I was dating at
the time.
I was in my twenties.
I was very young at the time and uh,
I was with a couple of my buddies and we
were talking and this guy was,
he was bringing up that this guy was
having some crazy problem with his
girlfriend.
And I said,
Oh yeah,
I go,
she's,
she's crazy,
and here's the problem.
He didn't want to get rid of it because
she's fucking hot.
And I go,
she's like,
who's that girl from real housewives?
Real housewives or desperate housewives?
Terry what?
Teri hatcher.
This was back like she was in one of
those fucking movies,
one of those summer movies way back in
the day.
You know,
Teri Hatcher is a few years older than
me.
So this was like,
well,
I'm talking this,
this conversation took place in the
nineties.
So I,
I think the way I described a den,
I said like a young Teri hatcher and
this girl got so mad,
she got so mad at me that I use Teri
Hatcher,
a young Teri hatcher to describe.
And I remember sitting there going,
what?
What?
I just said,
Oh,
here's your,
you're such an asshole.
And I'm like,
what did I do?
I was talking about,
this guy's got a girlfriend who's hot.
She's hot,
like a young Teri hatcher.
There she is.
Oh yeah.
Too stupid.
Hot,
confusing.
But she was in like some movie where I
forget what the fuck the premise of the
movie was,
but there was a guy in the movie that
couldn't do,
couldn't deal with the fact that she was
telling cash.
Confused.
Anyway.
Um,
my point is this,
I didn't get it.
I was like,
what did I do wrong?
Of course she was mad that I didn't use
her as an example of someone really hot.
Oh God.
Sometimes she was familiar with.
Sometimes I know now see here's a
problem as comics,
like we were like,
uh,
you know,
we like to think in logical ways,
but we also like to analyze things.
So like,
you know,
so like she asks like,
Oh,
if I feel ugly or you have to be like,
you have to know at that moment,
oh,
is she fishing for me to say
compliments?
Compliment or if like,
or like she just woke up and sometimes
you just,
you,
you have to just be like,
oh,
you look so great
today.
I think you've got to preemptively just
throw those in there.
Just just,
just fucking decorate the plate with it.
Here's the thing,
and you know what's weird,
she knows you don't believe it at this
particular time.
I think she's beautiful.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not saying fucked up.
No,
I'm saying she's going to know now
I'm talking about fucking bullshit.
I think they know when they just need it
and they know,
you know,
they want you to know that they just
need this right now whether you want to
or not.
They just know they,
they know that and then that's what
they're really connected to.
Oh,
he's doing what he was doing that thing
for me to,
for me.
Right.
That's all it is.
Do this for me.
And some girls don't need that shit at
all.
Some girls just don't need it.
They're like,
hey shit,
that wasn't nice.
Something else go like,
you save that,
save that and get that deck ready.
Been dating the girl in her twenties is,
is uh,
you know,
that's why I had to start doing boxing
because it's 15.
Like I said,
yeah.
I gotta like,
you know,
I'm like,
I got the things I have to do after
work.
Magic,
you know what I mean?
Yeah,
man,
because in a few years,
I mean that's the thing is like there's
a definite deterioration of your
physical being as you get into your
forties.
If you don't keep up,
if you keep looking at me,
if you keep it fun,
cuddly guy.
But I gotta get.
I gotta get there.
It's so.
It's my fault.
I put,
I put on weight,
so I walked by a donut shop and our gain
like two pounds.
What do you eat?
I just a horrible.
Horrible.
Yeah,
that's the thing.
Yeah.
So you die.
It's not good.
Now die.
I've got to get that dialed in gear,
but I don't,
I don't mind eating wild.
No.
My problem is this,
if it's in front of my plate,
if it's all my plate,
I'll eat it.
So I have to cut down on what's on my
plate.
Well,
when I met you,
you were thinner.
Yeah,
but I am.
My weight has always fluctuated.
You know why I remember this?
I'll never forget this.
We both a good friend,
Ari Shaffir.
I'm in the hallway at the comedy store.
I just got back from the Middle East,
so I was eating like a fucking Arab
prince over there.
Just just a fat fuck.
When I came back,
I've been mid conversation with Ari and
in conversation he leans over and he
grabs my cheek.
I'm talking about my car.
He,
he,
he grabs my cheek and he goes like this.
He squeezes it and he goes,
hey,
what's going on?
Let me say something.
I went to the gym the next day and I
signed up with,
with a,
with a personal trainer like that next
day because the way he did it,
I was like,
Oh shit.
It was like,
I forgot.
So I had to just get back to it.
I just been comfortable.
Well,
he's a comic,
you know,
he saw vulnerability.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The devil that he is
just hire a train.
But the thing is man,
just I'm doing the box and man,
I just started to box and I can.
You can get someone to
do like meal plans for you.
I know there's a bunch of those
companies that will make you healthy to
keep.
Yeah,
you keep them in the fridge.
See,
I,
I want to just do it.
I know I can because I've done it on
your own.
Yeah,
I did.
I was Vegan for a year,
you know,
because I did it.
I was my God,
I was crazy.
But you don't want to mess me up as I
did at the end of the year.
I did that master cleanse.
What's a master cleanse?
Remember the master cleanse with Cayenne
pepper and a and a maple syrup and
that's all you ate for a week.
Okay.
That shit I did it for.
He's supposed to have a 10 days.
I got to day five.
Then the two days of you got to let your
body get used to like having salad and
soup.
And then I had a fat burger who like,
I was bad.
I went from not eating meat from a year,
but you know,
what I learned from being Vegan for a
year is that the meat is not
necessarily.
The main course is just a side dish with
everything else.
So if you have a good thing of Broccoli,
a good thing,
corn,
a good thing of mushrooms,
and then you have a good thing,
a steak that you don't have to have the
steak and then you could have some great
side dishes.
Okay,
well there's a lot of people that eat
carnivore diet now,
so a lot of people that are eating just
meat.
Very interesting.
I think it's all about moderation,
man.
I don't know.
You don't even notice.
It's different for different people,
but you work out your workout guy.
You got to work out a lot.
You got monkey bars out there.
I've been working out twice a day.
Well,
there you go.
My main thing is one hard workout a day
and one less,
less hard workout a day.
Now if you think,
if you didn't do that,
that your physical,
your physical physically change.
I would diminish for sure because when I
take time off,
if I take time off,
I,
I noticed diminishing maybe,
but maybe that,
but also let's say how proper or average
health or even above average health is
here.
Maybe what you're doing brings you up
here,
so that diminishing you're talking
about,
it's just going to bring you to a more
average normal level,
but still in great shape.
Yeah.
Maybe you're.
Maybe you're overdoing it.
I'm just wondering if we're doing it
because I monitor everything.
I'm making sure that my health is good
and my body's in good shape,
but I just know that if you don't use
it,
you lose it.
There's just a fact that and when I say
a workout twice a day,
what it means is usually I'll do yoga
during the day and then at night I'll
lift some weights or I'll run the hills
and then at night I'll lift weights.
You're not doing a navy seal workout
twice a day?
No,
no,
no.
One.
One of the workouts is like pretty calm.
The weightlifting workouts are almost
always pretty calm unless I'm doing like
a cardio kettlebell workout or something
intense at this gym they have.
You could do the boxing and then another
days you can come and you could do like
a a weight training.
I'm an active weights and that kind of
stuff,
so I'm going to start doing that one
too.
I bet.
A big thing with you is just what you're
eating,
bro.
Yeah.
The animal cookies to the circus animal
cookies I have in my kitchen right now.
Good.
It's not good.
Not good,
but if they come in these little packs,
but I have a pack of 50 so every time I
have one I think,
well I'm only
habit.
Get it.
You know,
so I,
I have to.
I love to eat.
I'm going not just to,
but the way get calls on me so fast.
It's so annoying that it just sits in my
gut area.
Especially as you get shaped like an
ostrich.
It's hard to know what I mean.
I'm big in the middle,
middle legs.
That's harder and harder as you go.
Oh,
that's what's happening right now.
I got to stop.
That's why you got to keep up.
That's the whole thing.
No,
man.
You got to maintain like I work on my
comedy.
I have to work on my physical.
At the same time,
you'll feel better.
I want to feel that way more energy to
cut out the sugar grains.
Here we go with the sugar to cut out
sugar and grains,
you'll lose 30 pounds.
Cut out everything that is delicious.
Just eat salads and fish.
Eat healthy.
Have some red meat,
but in moderation.
Don't eat crazy.
I'm holding on fries.
A lot of chicken.
A lot of fries.
Drink a lot of water.
Fries are bullshit.
Mostly potatoes and oil.
Could he get none of that?
Really?
We.
We have.
When's the last time you had some fries?
Yeah,
exactly.
but you just can't.
Can't,
can't have it all the time.
I know.
Moderators all moderation mattering.
Night it in a nice Italian restaurant.
It's a pasta last night.
Fuck.
Narrow Salsa.
Some shrimp.
It was delicious.
We just had the same meal I had last
night.
Yeah,
I do follow World Diablo.
Diablo
the devil's in the details.
Yeah.
I like.
It.
Tastes good,
but I just don't allow myself to do it
very often.
Most of the time I eat real clean.
Good for you.
I'm trying to get their body.
You could do it.
I know.
Don't get defensive.
I've done it.
I'm in your corner.
I'm not going to feel angry.
Is Mad at me because I know I should be
doing to run out of here and go right to
the gym.
I'm just going.
I'm not going to leave the building.
I'm just gonna.
Go right over there.
That's what I'm saying.
Building plenty of equipment.
We could work out side by side.
I know I should have brought my stuff.
I got stuff for you.
And of course this is just me trying to
get out of it already.
You know what I mean?
Joe,
I got my shoes.
I didn't bring my orthopedics.
I think for comics it's like it's,
it's,
it's important to alleviate a certain
amount of angst.
You want to go on stage with a certain
amount when you're upset and you know,
you like pissed off and shit,
but you don't want to go upset onstage
hating yourself.
Right.
You know,
I don't like comics that go onstage
drunk,
right?
I don't like how they they need this
alcohol or or,
or people that think we'd like people to
think we like out of my saying,
weed makes you lazy,
but lazy people shouldn't smoke week.
Ryan.
I know what you're saying.
Well,
as a person who smokes weed,
it really bothers me because I'm not
lazy at all and I just,
I hate that connection between lazy
people in week because I don't think
that's.
I don't think that's what makes you
lazy.
No,
no,
I agree.
That's why I'm saying I'm not saying it
makes you lazy,
you know,
but if you're already lazy and then you
do.
This is not going to be a winning
combination.
It's not just that it just looks
because.
And you blame it on the week.
Jr Smith,
I think.
I think that was a weed situations.
Gerrit Smith from the.
No,
you don't even know.
Cleveland capital.
Jerry jumps into press the microphone.
I don't know what we're talking about.
Cable Cavaliers.
He did something really stupid.
He was like two.
It was like three,
four seconds left there.
Their tie ballgame.
Right.
One of the other guys that the fleet,
the why he misses the free throw,
Jr Smith grabs the ball instead of
putting it up to win the game,
he dribbles out because he thought that
they were up and the look on his face
was like that.
Kinda like,
I've seen this.
Hi Look,
I'm not saying he,
but I heard stories that he smokes a lot
of weed.
So.
And I'm saying like those weed people
out there,
like there's an example of it.
There are brilliant people that smoke
weed.
They are successful.
The look on his face.
What the fuck man?
First of all,
how Jack is Lebraun.
Look at those fucking six,
nine to 50,
probably six percent.
Body fat.
The shoulders on that 33 years old.
Two.
And he's getting better.
Yes.
It's unbelievable.
Shoulders are fucking epic.
Yeah man.
There's another picture of him like
straight on where he lives.
He literally looks like an Avenger.
Like it could be like some sort of like,
keep him the fuck away from Jeff
Novitsky.
Look at the picture,
look at their picture of them right
there.
That one word,
Jeremy Smith is smiling too.
We'd look on high as fuck.
Oh,
that's a high guy.
And I think that owners understand other
stoners.
I think he got like a.
He had a little blame,
a brain slip.
I guarantee he did,
you know,
pain.
You $17,000,000 or they paid him off to
try to drag it into seven games high as
fuck.
You guys go.
That's boom.
That's him.
Yeah.
But there's plenty of pictures of me
that looked like that to where I'm
sober.
They didn't catch you.
You could just blanket.
You could just look up jared Smith.
Hi.
I'm sure there's a website so he smokes
a lot of weed.
Smoking weed.
There you go.
Well this doesn't like one of those
things with the MBA has it in their
contract that they don't test for weed.
They do tests,
but it's not as stringent as everywhere
they test for weed.
But these guys are all getting high.
Like it's the locker room for a pool
for,
you know,
I told you I play pool pool.
Marijuana is a performance enhancing
drug.
One hundred percent.
It makes me my game.
Don't believe you,
you don't have to.
I'm telling you,
it does not make your paint better.
It does.
It makes you more sensitive.
Trust me is the reason why basketball
players find it better to.
It puts them into some sort of a zone.
Now are you saying that Lebron James
Needs?
We'd know like there's a lot of pro pool
player,
so we're top of the food chain and don't
do anything right,
but a lot of guys who like it say that
we'd bumps their game up quite a bit and
I'm one of them.
It makes me play better.
I'm telling you,
you don't know because you don't smoke.
Wait,
can you do an experiment?
I want to express.
I want you to play.
You're going to.
You're going to play pool.
You play?
No,
you're going to play pool sober.
Okay.
And then you're gonna.
See your results.
And then see the problem is if weapon
experiments sober and then I smoke,
I smoke pot and get high.
I will have been warmed up for the
playing pool sober and I'll definitely
play better.
High separate.
It's separate days.
But the problem with separate days is
have to,
your body has to be like perfectly in
tune and running to get real accurate
results because one day I could have
lifted weights,
which fucks up your pool game.
Like nothing.
Here we go,
telling you,
just pick two of my best games.
I was medicated Matt Barnes on his game
day use of marijuana.
Matt Barnes who will not be in the hall
of fame.
Who did the player?
He.
He was all right.
But he's a role player.
I want to.
I want Michael Jordan to come out and
say that.
Then I'm going to be like,
oh wow.
Know I want.
I want someone like that.
They'll go,
don't tell me what the role players will
see.
You're saying this though,
as a guy who doesn't smoke pot,
I'm telling you for Jujitsu,
for Jujitsu,
it's a huge part of the Jujitsu world.
Lot of people get high and then to
Jujitsu and they say it makes the game
better.
What's the practical use of Jujitsu?
Well,
if you and I were in a fight that would
kill you,
that I think he would kill me,
kill me anyway,
but telling me the practical.
Okay,
so just for that moment,
but any other.
But no,
no.
It's not just you want to be high.
If you were to walk into your car late
at night and then three guys came at you
and you would,
would you want it to be asking what's
the perfect circumstance?
Then you're late at night.
You're headed to your car.
I don't think you understand marijuana.
I'm just saying.
Would you want to bother them?
Would you prefer to be sober or high?
Neither one be fine with either one.
Yeah.
Oh good.
Good.
Then depends.
I mean I'm not going to be able to do
anything different if I'm sober or.
Hi,
I'm fit,
but we're not talking about drunk now.
If you said what?
I want to be drunk or sober,
fuck you.
I'd want to be sober.
Oh no I'm not.
I didn't.
I get it.
If I'm worried about getting kit and I'm
not sure about reaction time or one of
the things about pod is it makes you a
little bit paranoid so it puts you on
edge.
It makes you aware of Shit.
The other thing is it focuses you like
very cleanly on what you're doing.
Like if you're do this out here,
just really strong there.
I didn't know I like it,
but if you're a drawing or music or
something along those lines.
We really try to focus a lot of writing.
A lot of people really like it for those
things because it makes you really focus
on what you're doing,
but then.
But then I think what happens then is
that that whatever they were doing on
that,
they don't apply it to.
Because I know a lot.
We all have a lot.
We both have a lot of potheads comedian
friends.
Yeah,
but there's some of them.
I know that when I started with them,
I know that they're not doing what
they're doing now that they're in,
that they didn't keep going.
It exceed their expectations and I know
proud of it was because of the pot.
I don't think it is.
I think the pod is just common
denominator uses an excuse.
It's not.
The common denominator is no work ethic.
That denominator is.
It did.
It didn't help to work ethic.
I don't think it hurts or helps.
I think it's just.
It's a factor of study on this.
Yeah.
I mean the study would be skewed because
a lot of failures that get high all the
time would be in the study,
but a lot of winners that get high on
the time don't want to talk about it and
I was,
by the way,
I'm with you 100 percent on this.
I.
What I hate is that the people that
don't have any work ethic,
they look at somebody with a work ethic
that smokes weed and then say,
well look,
they made it because they smoke weed.
And I'm like,
no.
They would have made it without the
weed.
Yeah.
They would have made it without the way.
That's what I'm saying.
Before I ever smoked weed.
I was already on television.
He had a warner brothers cd as no start
smoking weed until like 2000.
I'm not.
I'm not listening.
I'm not anti weed,
but I just think that with anything
there should be moderation.
Yes.
No,
I agree.
Like one of the best things I did last
year was Ari and Tom Segura and Bert
Kreischer nine.
We did this sober October thing where I
saw.
I saw no booze,
no pot,
and we had to do 15 hot yoga classes in
the month and I learned a lot in that
month.
I really did.
Are you different?
Are you different person because of it?
No,
it was good.
You got to get out of here.
Yeah.
Not really.
Jesus.
Thirty to 20 bro.
Yeah,
I'm doing another one.
I'm going going,
going to see Barry Katz,
you if you can believe that.
Congratulations.
Barry Katz is a podcast.
That's going to be an interesting day
for me.
Was we just.
Oh,
about the pot,
but I forget what was going to say stone
and thought.
No,
it's not.
It's not whether or not you smoke pot.
It's whether or not you get things done
and whether or not you write out what
you're supposed to do,
whether or not you actually try to
achieve goals,
whether or not you're.
You're actively trying to improve
whatever you're doing,
whether you build cars or make carpet,
cabinetry.
It's just about whether or not you're
working towards succeeding and and
improving.
And I agree.
Listen,
I agree with it.
I'm not anti pot.
I'm not.
I shouldn't agree with based on evidence
of the people that are around a lot of
us.
We should be anti.
I should be antipop dude.
I know a lot of people that were there
were made me sad like I'd run into him
at the comedy store and they'd be like,
Bro,
you got any weed on you,
man.
You.
Yeah,
and I'd be like,
you're not doing anything.
You're not doing anything with your life
and you want some weed.
Go get a job.
Get some wheat.
Yeah.
But then you also see guys like Ari who
get high all the time and they're
constantly working.
Or Doug Benson,
who's like the most functional pothead
I've ever met in my lifestyle.
All Day he's a weird one,
or snoop dogg there people,
but these are people that are.
They are the exceptions,
not the rule.
I wonder.
There's a lot of people on Wall Street
that get high.
There's a lot of people that are
involved in like the tech world that get
high a lot and what people think about
it is that,
look,
it's like everything else,
man.
It can be good for you or it could fuck
your world up.
My ratio.
I think there's some benefit to it and
what the benefit is,
vulnerability,
creativity.
It makes you feel vulnerable.
It makes you.
Things makes you look at me.
People call it paranoia.
I just think it broadens your,
your awareness.
I think as a standup you already have a
level of vulnerability just going on
stage and talking about things.
For sure.
So that's like my.
I'm sure that some of that.
I just,
I just feel like that's my drug.
Does a good drug.
I mean it's,
it's definitely not one.
It's gonna ruin your life.
Hopefully.
Yeah.
Unless you tell a bad planet of the apes
jokes on twitter,
on that area,
and
she got that old school.
Yeah,
she got that abm from the motherland.
I hope she bounces back,
but I don't know if she will.
Has Anybody bounced back from this new
era of fucking hate and anger?
No one has bounced back.
I don't think like Aziz wasn't taken out
well the show was canceled or anything
like that.
Have a show except the Netflix show and
he didn't do anything to the point where
it was like a crime,
but a lot of people went after him like
that.
Sam,
Samantha Bee lady went after him and Oh,
she's going hard to everybody.
Yeah.
She's going hard and everybody was
saying,
yeah,
it becomes a stick at a certain point.
No,
it loses credibility.
Sort of just.
She means it means well.
It's an important voice.
The problem with going hard on a person
is you're only getting one version of
what happened.
You know,
like we're not talking about going hard
on a person who committed a crime.
You're going hard on a person that's
involved in an interaction with two
people.
What I would like to see though is like
someone like Samantha Bee to like ask
Aziz to come on her show.
Oh,
you wouldn't do that and had him do it.
No,
but that's what I'm seeing is that we're
missing.
That would be you wouldn't use already
attacked.
It's solid in entertainment.
I mean it's like,
isn't that the whole point of it
probably hurts for him.
Well,
as he can,
he can handle himself in that forum.
I would like to see that.
I see even that.
I think those forums are hard to do.
You know,
I did a bench Pieros podcast that just
aired yesterday and he is a Sunday
special thing that he does and is an
hour long and every 15 minutes he
stopped the conversation,
does a commercial and while I was
sitting there doing it,
I was like,
I really liked guy.
I really like talking to him.
Brilliant Guy,
but this is not the best way to stay
loose and have a conversation like this
pod catcher.
I get you.
This is the best format that says it is
the kind of conversations that we've had
over the past three hours.
This is the best format because you just
talk nothing.
Nothing interrupts you.
There's no sensors.
There's,
yeah,
there's no thing that you have ahead of
time.
Please don't talk about this.
And also like it's best with friends.
Like,
you know,
I care about you,
your friend,
you know,
we're going to have fun and there's no.
I'm not looking to get you to be weird
with you.
Gotcha.
Podcast.
Trying to have fun with you.
And we had fun.
You know,
and this,
this is like the best format to get to
understand people.
I think what we're missing today in this
world,
in this is this is just
an open thought.
People need
more opportunities to be cool with each
other and less it take advantage of less
opportunities to attack each other.
And I see a lot of attacking lately and
I don't know if the,
the attacking is because there have been
so many egregious crimes that need to be
corrected.
Like Harvey Weinstein or like,
you know,
fill in the blank,
but all the other monsters that have
been out there,
it's late.
I'm not picking on people.
Cute.
I'm going to keep texting you.
Yeah.
Your phones on your watch that isn't
that weird.
It's different all the time.
So he's changing that x.
What happens when you hit that?
You hit the x and then it just goes to
whatever else.
I think somebody is listening to our
podcasts right now.
So.
And somebody texted my girlfriend and
she's like,
actually just sent me a text message
right now.
You better not be married.
I don't know what that means,
but
I'm hoping that it all balances out.
I hope that it comes back around and
people just think,
well,
human being just be nice to each other
just by example is all it is.
It's a hard thing.
We have to lead by example.
That's why I'm saying these issues that
men as a man,
what we're having out here is we forgot
how to be gentlemen.
We've done.
And I think that if like say the disease
situation,
if he had just been a gentleman,
I don't know what he did.
I don't know if you've read that.
And obviously what I read the story,
it was just,
he was trying to get with her,
you know,
they were texting back and forth and it
was like,
Yo,
y'all already went to dinner and they
ended up at his place and it was,
you know,
it was like maybe you don't bring a
check that you barely know to your
place.
Now maybe there's two different types of
short.
Right?
If you're too.
But if you're a guy like that,
I mean,
you know,
if you heard Tony talk about it,
women are throwing themselves at you all
the time.
What are you supposed to do?
Act like a gentleman is what I'm saying.
Get up,
get up,
excuse the excuse.
Shouldn't be as like,
you know,
like that's like a man way to say it to.
It'd be like,
you know,
you've got all these hot chicks.
One of us will say no to these hot
chicks.
Yeah,
maybe you should.
Wow.
Look at you all judgmental.
Here's a guy who had the girl come back
to his place.
She was,
she would say no to her.
I should have.
That's my shit.
I should have stopped it,
but I let my ego get in the way.
I let my own,
like,
you know,
insecurity.
It'd be like,
well this got really.
You didn't let me.
So let me,
let me go through.
Hey,
just because you can doesn't mean you
should.
Let's end ended with that.
I think we should.
And when is your special?
Why did you June ace on showtime testing
them.
That's this weekend.
Friday night on a Friday night,
but I'll also be at the Irvine Improv on
Friday.
So you all weekend.
I'll be at Irvine so if you want to come
see me there.
And then showtime.
I'm dying up here.
Is Aaron Right now on showtime?
Uh,
episode six will be next Sunday.
You know,
so a check me out at Erik Griffin.
I love you.
Beautiful.
Thanks brother.
Appreciate being on
me.
You know what I mean?
I really appreciated it.
Yeah,
do it again.
You still have your own.
I will.
You'll be.
I'll be honest,
my first guest on the aircraft and
pocket.